[Music]
[Music]
so
all right the realm what's going on
mike check mic check warlord 1015
five dollar super shot bang bang
notification gang we ain't here early
had to hit it with the philly early it
was good on that flame what's going on
christopher what's going on back for
dead hustle and motivate my man
what's going on let me know the levels
is good fonzarelli gaming i see you
i see you six slam good podcast last
night went away dragon what's going on
chillin chilly all right no doubt no
doubt back for day bye guys phantom
cracking what's up
all right y'all know what it is we're
gonna get um obsidian up in here attic i
need a mic check though talk to the
people
testing testing can you guys hear me yes
uh quite
uh hustle wait a couple more days and
then uh we're gonna see where that
package is
all right no doubt hollow to get in and
on what's going on
the itch you can't reach that's a new
day
i like that what's good doing man early
you know willie waldo you fulfilling
because i know that bang bang
notification game that was a crazy
seagull record i remember i love that
record
daniel what's up rocco corey what's up
let me see what's it man pecan fusion
what's going on
yeah man so look we're gonna get
obsidian in the building
you know and uh the king will be pulling
up so i will be pulling up
and we're gonna try to have a good show
enzo what's up so we will see y'all
in a bit and uh hopefully be a fun one
for y'all
talk to y'all soon
ah damn centric h what's good over there
ten dollar super chat whoa
rick flair voice i got you all right now
oh he from brooklyn
oh you just let that use all that state
property he was repping that beans okay
i see you
nine lives what's up baba baba jade kay
what's up y'all dressed like 75 yeah
yeah it was it was it was a classic
night
it was a classic night tough dumpling
what's going on rest in peace black rock
for real
rest of please that's that was my joint
whoa that was my joint
anyway def mobile i see you all right
we'll be back for real because king will
come in and you know how to copyright
strike school when you come in with his
music
i hate you
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
second all right the lords have arrived
lords of obsidians have arrived by check
i want to shout out acg brother thank
you for the
wow for the 50 super chat i have nothing
good to add to this discussion
here's the game's worth of super chat
because you are more fun than most
gamers truly
humbling lord acg my man appreciate you
brother
king's here
[Music]
so
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not
mind go ahead and uh find yourself a
spot get comfortable grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical
and yeah i'll be eating these rappers
but that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original y'all so dramatical i know
[Music]
look i um you could say that i'm very
spoiled feeling to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boil you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i've
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger that's
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show
if you would not mind go ahead and uh
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i am well it's not important who
i am
uh what's important is that you are
pulling up to the iron lords podcast
right now as we speak and uh i guess i'm
here to keep you entertained until it's
time to get this show started so um
look you gotta mess up and turn me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical
and yeah i be eating these rappers but
that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original y'all so dramatical i know it's
random but i am addicted to flipping the
sample and making it flammable this is
that
fire this is up in the apartment they
call the department and i get the blame
still i'll be running collecting them
reigns you just a target when i'm in the
range i was the hardest to start
regardless
check my vote follow on twitter but i'm
anti-social
[Music]
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boil you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i've
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again hear you hear you
man welcome to the show
if you would not mind go ahead and uh
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lord's
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look you gotta mess up and turn me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical
and yeah i'll be eating these rappers
but that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original y'all so dramatical i know it's
random but i am addicted to flipping the
sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we were messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
[Music]
is
[Music]
me for attic if i can imagine this
cooler give you some advice and invite
your girl to your squadron
cause if you don't give her that option
you're gonna be single player like siren
you're gonna get tossed in the bushes by
king david
royalty and not a pretender detrimental
to an elemental what's an avatar
that's cool but i got bad news even if
you really was that jew king david still
be the king of the statues
since the juvenile i've been cursed with
a curse to be musical and if you hate it
we'll meet in the crucible wasn't it
nothing it's cool and it's beautiful we
let you know that your dreams are
pursuable whatever you want to do then
it's doable if you got work on a sunday
it's suitable cause you can listen to
this in your cubicle
on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the lord's day
[Music]
all right mike check my check
testing and we are live
welcome to the i launch podcast and the
lords of gaming.net
episode number 205 and it's another
glorious sunday we're back at the round
table on the lord's date
i'm extremely excited about our special
guests and we've got
obsidian entertainment
the outer world's latest dlc interest in
square enix
and the latest ps5 firmware to discuss
so we're going to get right into it
i want to introduce both a lady and the
lord whose native talents not only
contribute to critically acclaimed new
ip but truly brings fresh life
into the sci-fi rpg genre whether it be
its compelling narrative choices or
hilarious companions we meet along the
way
all done with a whodunit feel and
halcyon
murder mystery vibes introducing
both the game director and narrative
designer of the iconic
outer worlds and developers from the
legendary
obsidian entertainment the pride of
xbox game studios whose strange
inhabitants on eridano's
only true purpose is to make you smile
laugh from cali and kind enough to make
their debut
into the realm of the lords my fam
lady megan starks and lord the tai podar
of obsidian
entertainment how are you lords doing uh
thank you so much for having us
thank you i i want that intro recorded
and just
i wanted to like every time i show up at
a meeting
i try
[Laughter]
[Music]
you know the little intro they do in
like wwe
oh man you you both are lords at what
you do
tremendous respect and pleasure to have
you both in the realm so it's only right
we show you the proper respect so first
of all how are you guys doing just
rela in in in game mode and relax mode
like how you guys do it
personally let's start with a ladybug at
first yeah pretty good
yeah it feels really nice to have it out
like um
it's crazy how you know we started with
such a small team
in the beginning and then it just kind
of grows over time and then
you know a year later you're like wow i
think it
i always think game development is like
how people talk about childbirth where
they're like oh you kind of forget the
pain of it and you only remember the
good parts but then you immediately want
to do it again
um so yeah they already rolled us onto
new projects and
that's great good to hear lord the time
a pleasure to have you in the room
how are you holding up are we getting a
chance to relax a little bit
a little bit yeah i was i was i'm really
been i've been looking forward to this
interview this is
it's one of my favorite things to just
talk to other people about the games we
enjoy in the games we make
um the team that worked on murder on
eridanos pushed so hard to get
this dlc out to the fans it really was
like a labor of love
from everybody on the team yes so i'm
i'm really happy with the way it landed
and i'm happy that fans had a good time
with it
absolutely we're happy the way it landed
too yeah
so before we do the intros lord saw we
want to take care of it set the tone
early with the realm
of course of course so we have a the
everborn saga with the five dollar super
chat
the lords are in the building bx stand
up have a great show fellas thank you my
brother
then we have i face crook with the five
dollars
sunday is the lord's day shout out from
chicago god bless you all likewise thank
you god
then we have the wandering dutch with
the five pound super chat
all right i'm retiring from podcasting
how the hell do we match a custom
freestyle rap intro
dance level up you know what's good yeah
for sure for sure then we have flame
with the five dollars but
here ye hear ye we got obsidian royalty
in here
so sit yourselves down and show some
respect that's right
that is correct prior to xbox game
studios exactly
and we are all caught up so uh ladies
and gentlemen as you know
we only have lord natai and lady megan
for a limited amount of time so we thank
you very much for your super chats but
the vast majority of them will be read
after yes
yes yeah at the end of the show so again
thank you very much gotta respect the
time so you already know we got the four
horsemen of gaming
those original lords of the realm here
at the round table with those time
sensitive because obsidian is limited
time here he's talking to you king
the difficult game conqueror lord of his
own world
and the how of the young wolf mommy
lord addict how we doing sir i'm doing
pretty good i just realized with new
guests you making me sound real
egotistic right there wow
i finally figured it out i'm gonna keep
my
intro short because king gonna take half
of it but uh i appreciate everyone for
coming through and i appreciate our
guests
and of course we have our most technical
gaming lord the solo gamer who lives for
the single-player selfish experience
and also the softstradamus the lord of
clarity and patreon of the iron bank
my man lord sovereign how we doing sir
i'm doing fantastic i'm doing fantastic
i'm so excited to have our guests here
today
um very quickly big shout out to
everyone over at the shop podcast for
having me on last night uh
yes sir fantastic time with my bro yeah
man
i didn't realize that that was yeah the
shop podcast was the first
uh interview that i did solo uh out of
my opinion
and that was that was some time ago
annual podcast rounds how kind
of yes i know sorry
and very quickly i i i couldn't help
myself i've been playing and will be the
show
oh you went all the way in i listened
man you know me i had this oh well
they said xbox people don't buy games
that's true
did you buy that king who me nah he's
not buying that oh no no
i already downloaded time we got guests
we have company
has been it sir yes sir thank you
appreciate you
we have the incredible hulk of this aka
the access gamer
oh the prophet of xbox king of the
statues who demands nothing less than
that premium experience
it is the leader of the fraud alert
movement
oh beloved lord king how are we doing
sir
better than ben asprin yeah yeah can't
go into a fight like
oh my god anyway uh let's get past that
uh been playing outright as outstanding
um and also i had to binge play the dlc
right so uh i noticed very quickly
that they fixed my biggest gripe which
was biggest right the last time when i
ended the game
um out of worlds uh and i got to the
first dlc
i was already past the point where i can
actually
access it and i was phineas i was
literally
so frustrated i was so upset i was
really pissed off because i had to start
my character fresh
i was really upset so this time when i
went in
they had a prompt that told you we can
take you back from this part right here
and at the
and i think that's great fan service
because they listen to the fans they
listen to the gripe they listen to the
problem
and they fix it immediately so i was
immediately
able to jump into the new dlc so anybody
that's worrying about that part right
there you don't have to worry about that
so see you're saying they gave you a
rewind button well
yeah you know what because it's
definitely necessary for
individuals that's ignorant like myself
i mean because i found out that i was
probably in a very minute
uh minority in doing so just playing the
game
on one save and getting going they tell
you like
eight times there's no return after this
they didn't tell you there's no return
for your dlc that's true
okay but they fixed it though i don't i
don't care about anything else but other
than it fixing it
and it started off really great so i i
can't wait to get into this interview i
was waiting for this all
doubt and of course we have the
gaming ninja himself the shinobi lord
cognito spreading that wrongness in the
roman iop not telling you what you want
to hear but what you need to hear
obviously got my murder at aerodynamics
dlc completed that we will be discussing
that
and um yeah shout out to the last word
we had all my man ill physics on
really knowledgeable guys so if you want
to get your luna shooter on you want to
know what's going on with ladies with
destiny and maybe bungie's new ip go
check out the last word it is
up there now but uh now that we've
gotten into what the lords have been
playing
i want to focus on lady megan and lord
natai
the games industry experience and of
course what led them to the hottest
single-player sci-fi rpg from obsidian
and private division
the outer worlds but before we do that
let's give the realm a preview of their
latest dlc
that murder at irando's check it out
y'all
the discrepancy amplifier is now
operational
standing standing
standing
on the outer world of the outer
[Music]
but the deeper
[Music]
[Music]
somebody ends up dead
analysis confirms this is a corpse
[Music]
everywhere
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is all just some sort of publicity
stunt
all right we got that murder on ira
donald's love
going on thank you ralph for check it
out he said it looks lit the chat likes
it 9 out of 10. love the trailer
you already know so let's start with uh
lady beggar first uh
can you give a realm a brief background
of your specific role tenure at obsidian
and of course what led you to the outer
worlds alberta in iran is the dlc
oh okay so um i started at obsidian as a
narrative designer on tyranny
um and then i went on to pillage the
journey to
dead fire and then i joined outerworlds
after like a year and a half of begging
for them to let me on the team um but
just because like i'm such a fan of you
know fallout games and
i was really excited and i worked on a
sci-fi game with wildstar so i was like
really excited to work on it um i had a
lot of fun
i worked on um the sublight faction and
some different
um characters in the game like um sam
and i helped um
with vicar max and stuff like that and
then after the game came out
um we needed to make two dlcs basically
at the same time slightly staggered
and so the main team was
making uh parallel on gorgon and then
they asked if i could um
basically start up a small team with
about seven people to get the foundation
going for murder on eredana so that we
could be far enough along that when
parallel and gorgon
came out we could like finish up the
second dlc
so that's pretty much it that's a shout
out to vic
back that's one of my favorite
competitions what's funny is
the gangster figure i love it
i noticed you said pillows of eternity i
really like that game
tremendous tremendous and of course
let's get lord the tie in again
give the rob a brief background just on
your your role your tenure obsidian and
obviously
you know what led you to outer worlds um
so i actually started that obsidian
with the outer worlds um about four
years ago
uh i think my first day at obsidian was
basically okay so we're doing a game
and it's fallout meets firefly and we
don't have a name for it yet but here's
the general plot
so get to work so i've kind of been with
this project
like from the start all the way to the
end and it's it's been
it's been a real journey it it's been
weird like i
when obsidian told me hey we're going to
do
a fallout for the fans but it's not
going to be fallout because
you know we're sitting and we don't own
it okay this is this is going to make a
lot of people
very very happy and um it was
i think the reason i i kind of got into
it and really enjoyed the process
altogether is because i've been playing
rpg since i was like 12 or 13.
like it's kind of been my whole life
like i started with um you know d d
balder's gate the old school stuff so
that that style of role playing game
where you design a character give them
stats have all kinds of
uh conversation options is like kind of
in my dna like i've been doing that for
since i was a kid right
so so um you know when i when i got into
outer worlds and started designing
uh my attitude was what would the
younger version of me
really like to see in a game like this
and i've kind of been carrying that
through
that's awesome that's awesome you know
just to see i'm sorry sophie was going
to say something
no i just said fantastic well i i
noticed very early on
um the artistic style and the color
choices
is very vibrant yes it's it's you know
um so
when you said you know like uh the
contrast to fallout fallout
is very muted in colors very dark very
dreary
and when i launched out of worlds i
noticed like
right from the beginning it was very
vibrant was that a direct
choice in the beginning that you guys
decided to go with
yeah that's um basically um tim
kaine leonard boyarski and our art
director daniel alpert
got together and i believe came up with
all that type stuff and it was included
when we pitched it to the publisher like
this is going to be the look of the game
and
we they had some like sample branding
and stuff like that so it's something
very consistent from the beginning that
they wanted to stick with and i agree i
really like it i think
it's super it like i don't know it grabs
you as player
sometimes it pays off to be unique and
have a unique look
yeah i agree king it's so vibrant and
it's like it's just
you know this color overload but i like
it it just it brings you in i wanted to
um
ask and reference before we get to the
specifics of the dlc like
obviously the success you guys have had
initially you know you guys debuted i
believe it was like number two
npd at the time in 2019 you know what i
mean a couple of
awards along the way narratively it's
like so like how does it feel
you know a new ip to get some really
good reception let's
start with a tie first um i feel
vindicated
it's not like it's not about like me and
the team and and
outer worlds in general but this is like
a flag i've been carrying for a while i
strongly believe
pretty much everybody who plays and
enjoys video games loves role-playing
and nobody believes that because people
keep saying oh role-playing is this
little niche
and it belongs to a particular genre of
games but
everybody loves making a character
everybody loves getting into a character
everybody loves building up their own
little story like we used to do that
when we were kids
playing pretend and you know and that
that energy
is kind of still with us as adults so if
you have a mainstream rpg
that's narrative heavy it's big on
choices um
it uses it's it's big on reading i mean
you have like lots and lots of dialogue
options
and it does well to me that says there
is a really big audience
of players who just want to role play
and
you can you can it's like a it's a mind
that hasn't been
struck yet i think it the word
vindication is perfect
because when you think about the rpgs
and
how hardcore they are to see rpg
elements permeating
basically every single genre of gaming
now as somebody who loves rpgs he's like
wow this really it
you know it's it's not this it's not a
niche within a niche anymore
it is sort of it's like a standard of
game design like if you
look at if you just pick any aaa game
off the shelf
i guarantee you there's a 90 chance it's
gonna be open world
action rpg like that is that is the
formula now and it wasn't always like
that
yeah like even ips that didn't start
that way or that now
they're like yeah yeah i have one
question
um how did it feel like being one of the
first
to launch in game pass knowing that
you'll have millions of eyes
on your new ip at that point in time
because it literally changes the
landscape on
interaction on if somebody might be iffy
on a rpg and now they can go and try
because my son walked past and he saw
all the colors and he was like
what you playing daddy and i'm like i'm
playing out of worlds and he was like
it's in game pass i said yeah he said
i'm bi
i went straight upstairs um my question
is
oh what was when you got the word what
did you think and you know
what was the reception after that you
know with the team
that's interesting because when we
started the game it wasn't for xbox
right yet
so it was like um i think i think when
they pitched it they went to all the big
publishers and then it was that whole
like
oh if you're they're like big publishers
and i think
i kind of experienced this in like the
novel writing worlds more so i
i don't like hold me to it for games but
like one of the things i've seen is
they'll be like oh we're looking for
something new but then when you show
them something new they're like but what
audience will fit like how do we know
it'll make money so
we ended up going with private divisions
who took a chance on us and then once
the game was developed far enough
um i think it became very enticing um
and so um when we found out it was going
to be on game pass i think it just was
like oh
this is going to be like a huge
potential audience like it just opens
you up to people that you wouldn't
um have otherwise so it's just really
neat to see like you know it can reach
for more people and
it can open up the demographics of who
might be interested in playing it
um going forward so for me it was super
exciting um
and i think everybody on the team was
just stoked to see the reception when it
came out and stuff like that so
the main thing you want when you're
making a game is just have as many
people play it as possible and also have
them like it
that's pretty much it i feel like i feel
like game pass was really like a gateway
for a lot of players to pick up the game
who might not have done it otherwise
yeah and i get it like it's a it's a
depending on how fast you go it's about
like 15 to 30 hours
and like um if you're if you just see it
on the shelf right at your
brick and mortar game store assuming
people still go to those
uh you're gonna you're gonna hesitate a
little bit but if you've got game pass
and you see it and you're like all right
i've got you know
a week and i just want to play something
um then you might pick it up and you
might not
have before and to me that's that's
really what it's all about i mean of
course it's nice if a game is profitable
because the reason we do this is because
we know that there are going to be
people
who give you their time which to me is a
little bit more valuable than money
and we want to make sure that time is
well used so
game pass just gave a lot more people
an excuse to just pick up and play outer
worlds and they wouldn't have done that
before so it's been really gratifying
yes i absolutely agree i think again
it's that opportunity
and just like i said uh you know with
people who may have been on the fence
and
now it's just extra market this extra
group of gamers that now said hey okay i
have this service
it's in this service day and date why
not you know give it a shot but
i want to go back kind of reflect on
what uh megan alluded to initially with
um
like the pitch as far as like today's
games market because
the question i have for you is like as
far as the challenges you know again
it's
you know writing this single-player rpg
sci-fi
you know but also you got these
corporations you got these colorful
companions you got this
hilarious dark humor you guys yeah
so like how did you have any challenges
like now
pitching this to whoever the powers may
be you know or was there pushback
could you guys explain any challenges
you guys experienced during this process
the creative were you in on it inside i
saw because i was on jedfar at the time
i saw the updates we have like big
company
meetings where well before the pandemic
everybody get in a giant room
and then each team would give their
update so i got to see like the pitch
um presentation that they gave to the
publishers and then they would kind of
say like hey we're shopping around with
people and
update us occasionally but i didn't see
like i wasn't in
the meetings to see the response of
publishers um
but yeah i think in general it can be
tough to
um you have like if you're dealing with
a super big publisher i think they have
an expectation
of or having to prove it will make x
amount of money
in order to like invest the initial
budget you know even going up the ranks
so i think at the time
um it was just difficult to say like
yeah this is brand new but
don't worry people will really resonate
with it um so
it was really nice that private division
was specifically looking for new ips
like they were uh
i think middle sized you know publisher
imprint of um
take two 2k um and so basically they're
like that's exactly what they were
looking for and i remember
um they were really excited about it
which got the team super jazzed about it
too
and then um tim kaine had like made a
little sisty pig plushie where he like
sewed on like tumors
well that's what sold them on it i think
they saw that
i forgot about the plushies
i remember i remember we were sitting at
a company meeting and tim kaine
had like something behind his back that
he wasn't showing us and he's like
so we're meeting with publishers today
and i made this and like he just
pulls out assisted questions i'm like
tim what are you doing he's like don't
worry
it's going to charm them they're going
to get it
i swear like i don't i didn't like i got
to start looking for a new job
it's not a plushie part of me is like
what
what in god's name is going on right now
but like
i feel i feel so i feel like megan is
right like so much of making this work
is just
charming your publishers who are going
to be very scared of anything
new and different into just trusting you
a little bit and i think once the
the project was um far enough along that
you could actually
see what it was right it wasn't just a
bunch of
words on paper then people started to
understand like i remember
way back i think it was um the end of
2019 no end of 2018 we actually dropped
the trailer
for the outer worlds and people kind of
understood
what this game was that's when the
enthusiasm not just from the players
um but from the publishers and from the
studio itself started picking up
like when i think this is true for
anybody who does anything creative
whether you're making a game or writing
a novel or even like doing a podcast or
something like there's a point
where you just have to trust that it's
going to work out eventually it's like
you know what it is you're trying to do
but nobody else knows and you have to
like kind of prove it you got to have it
in your gut is that guy
you guys are like when when when you
feel it in your gut and you know what
you're doing is right
and you you can see it because i i
visualize it i'm uh
heavy on visible visualization and i and
i see it i can see the end of the road
but when you guys uh dropped the trailer
i remember going except cause i
i was going nuts i was absolutely going
crazy and i i knew it was coming i knew
the game was coming
and um i downloaded a wrong game by
mistake thinking it was
oh all right
that really goes crazy and i said and i
remember uh coming to the podcast that
sunday and i was like that's not what i
saw hey what game is that
right i was like and then i got
chastised by sovereign yes
the wild versus worlds outer wilds
is equally fantastic we liked it
so much we hired the writer really there
you go
listen i have no problem with it but you
know when you ordered steak and then you
get french fries
or something something else
which is really good but anyway to my
point
don't don't take me down that road stop
playing right that's
my point when i did get the game
it was everything that trailer promised
like from the beginning i was already
enthused into the world
and then after i finished it i was like
man then the dlc
popped up then i was like okay let's go
right back at it all right but this
second dlc
has a different tone and feel to it
you know right from the beginning
because you were brought in
from um like the game was giving you
bread crumbs
along with the cereals in the game so
you was like
you was enthused about it but you didn't
know much about it and then dania did a
whole dlc
i got a question was that part of it
like leaving those breadcrumbs and
knowing that this dlc would have
that impact and it was that oh there's a
story but look at the faces
should we tell them that we were just
flying by the seat of our pants
we should just pretend we should be like
yes we had it all in the bag exactly
when we did go to make the dlcs um
we did want to use elements from the
base game that we hadn't explored fully
so we were like you know what's
available that we can all pull together
and
you know but yeah i wish we had when we
were making the first game then like and
this is what the deal seats are going to
be
[Music]
so i think that's i remember when uh
when it was like me megan
uh tim and like a couple other designers
we were just sitting
in an office you know back when we could
still sit in an office and just working
on a whiteboard
um and we're like okay what do we want
to do what's exciting for us and then we
kind of settled on
this idea of a murder mystery would be
amazing i think we just saw knives out
and we're
we're told i was super inspired but i
was like oh
okay
are really the um the old school uh
like murder dime novels that you know
that you would have seen back in the 40s
and 50s that were like
really over the top and really silly and
and kind of inspired the whole noir
genre like that's part of our world's
dna too so we said
you know why don't we do something like
that and then what we started to do is
we just started to look at the elements
that go into a good murder mystery and
then we looked at our game and said okay
what of those elements exist in our game
what can we pull we thought uh halcyon
helen was super cool
um
[Laughter]
what the megan way of designing he's
like who do we kill let's go
here we go we basically started there we
were like who's dead
i mean that's perfect you work backwards
from there you know what i
what i really like about it is there's a
point in the story where they're like
okay you got all the suspects
who is it i'm just sitting here looking
at this looks like i ain't really felt
like i i'm not prepared for this
this question like what's funny is if
you click on to determine who it is
there's no going back they don't let you
go back they're sitting here looking at
this list i'm like
about to ruin someone's life
i want to ask a more general question
about how you guys
when it comes to narrative and
particularly dialogue
how do you guys sort of work that out
when you're
creating dialogue for these characters
especially in something like murdono's
where the dialogue is really
the core of how you get to the mystery
how do you guys what's your process if
you could
sort of shed a little bit of light on
that you guys like sit in the room
and sort of talk dialogue out between
each other to see if it sounds good like
you know do you have sometimes branching
like weird branching things going on
because
it i mean rpg dialogue obviously i want
to know who's the bad guy that's always
giving the bad lines at the bottom
it seems like a hilarious dude oh woman
i mean i think we had what um one
two three four five writers five and a
half we borrowed a couple
um so yeah they all they all have their
own characters
um but yeah i think um the process
for this dlc anyways is like with the
key suspects
um and the victim i had certain like
touchstones for their personality
thought i was like hey you know i was
kind of thinking they might be like this
but i like to leave a lot of
creative freedom because you know i
don't like to you know just
color in a box or whatever so it's just
a general direction
and then and mainly that was because i
wanted to make sure that there was
enough variety between them you don't
want to end up with um
you know iconic characters or characters
that are too similar
um and then once the writers do a pass
on it we usually do
what's called stubs which is like the
bare bones it's just um functional so
you can play test through it then we do
a first
writing pass and then um me
and natai and leonard and sometimes tim
will give feedback on it
and that's kind of like a general high
level or maybe a couple specific notes
and then once they do a second pass
we'll do like an edit or
final like hey make sure you add a skill
check here or this would be really
fun but a lot of it is like the writers
themselves just
knock it out like for pass they're
really good yeah
pretty impressive i want to ask the
titus too and reference kind of the same
thing that solves building on
you know because you got these great
dialogue choices these branches but
what's cool that out of worlds does
i feel is that based on your
specification how you spec your
character if you're very strong in you
know perception or
different things you know you can unlock
these dialogue choices that really can
take the conversation or the quest a
whole
different route so the question is one
with that how do you guys
determine that and then the other thing
is for the time specifically the voice
acting because i feel you got
the voice actors who and actresses that
you have
are amazing and hilarious shout out to
the prophet of profitability i always
laugh
when i uh you know there's a couple of
like i like phineas is hilarious
obviously you know administrator
ludovico he's
like this you guys have some of the most
funny
acted voice acted i think that's another
underrated strength of the game so i
want you guys to comment kind of on both
on that natai if you can you want to
start with that one
um this is a complex question but i'll
see if i can i can break it down a
little bit
um as as megan said we do start with a
structure because
it is a game first so every npc you talk
to
is going to have a purpose within the
quest right so like
administrator ludovico his conversation
is structured so that
he will take you through the mystery
he's the guy you constantly check in
with
uh when you talk to the prophet of
profitability or when you talk to um
spencer woldridge their conversations
are also structured in a way
that it works in the quest but at
obsidian we're really tough on writing
we can't have
npcs just feel like npcs like this is a
big
rule for our writers is we take that
structure right
that that fits the game and then we
write
into it so that make it organic exactly
so what you're experiencing is like
a good strong writing experience with
like uh good dialogue options plenty of
character plenty of real personality
still needs to function as a quest and
then on top of all that we also have to
add the things you were talking about
the perception checks
the intelligence checks the science
checks like it's got it you have all
these layers
that go into the narrative in our games
and then megan and leonard will come in
and give us like
30 notes because we got to make it
better just
to add on to that because that is
excellent advice like if anyone's 30
oh yeah um if anyone is watching that
you know
does writing yourself or whatnot i think
advice that i would say of how we
approach our characters is when you're
writing a character think um
what do they want and what are they
willing to do to get it and that kind of
determines like
how good or evil ranged they could be
and also like
the bounds of their personality and then
um
also uh trying to make them relatable
they don't have to be likable
but you have to understand their
motivation so even if you're
writing someone like you know handsome
jack for borderlands who's like the
extreme
evil you still understand why he was
doing what he was doing and
his context like the extremes he's
willing to go to for it so
yeah yeah i expect that spencer let me
double down
no i want to give you guys credit again
because what i think that you do
i haven't seen this since mass effect
where most games they have you know
you're the main character
and then you know it's rare that you
have you know these two companions and
stuff with you
but what i love that out of worlds does
is depending on who you have
with you they will insert themselves
into the dialogue and and have that and
not to spoil
that in this particular dlc there's
something that is phenomenal where it's
like this book
this good cop bad cop vibe oh my god and
whoever wrote it at the time that's your
[ __ ]
no no no no no no the outer wild strider
kelsey
[Laughter]
so basically what megan said is is
completely accurate is that
when we write our characters we do think
about what is their voice
what do they want what do they believe
and what are they willing to do to get
what they want
and i think the reason we put so much
emphasis on this is just out of respect
for the players like
players are going to be able to sniff
out bad writing video games have had bad
writing for 30 years
but but like players appreciate good
writing because we're treating their
time and their attention with respect
now to to dovetail into this talk about
voice actors
that's also where we approached um
that's actually how we approached
casting and directing voice actors uh we
gave them a script but
many of these voice actors we
specifically asked them to treat the
script
and their characters like real
characters like we'll give them notes
about who this character is
what is their background what do other
people think about them
what do they think of themselves what
are they afraid of yeah absolutely and
it's had like
so so when you get voice actors uh who
are very talented and you know their
grind
is basically go into the booth and do
like
50 attack lines for call of duty or
whatever whatever it's fine
that's what we do and then you give them
a script and we say okay here's a real
character
here's 250 lines they love it they eat
it up they're like oh my god i finally
have a chance to actually
have it you can see it in their
performances like they have a great time
um because we put effort into making the
material good enough
that they can invest their own talent
into bringing out those characters
they do put their own spin on it too
like i know i don't know if it's like
this for most writers but like
definitely for me every time i write i
hear a specific voice or like oh they
say it like this when i'm writing it and
then when you get into the booth
if you don't try and force the actor
into that if you just see
what they bring to the character a lot
of times it's like incredibly different
but so much better
yeah because you have a perception of
what you want it to be and then you
allow them to act
and that's really good that you give
them that freedom to bring
what they want to bring to the character
and if it works that way it's a little
bit more organic yeah i got got to
salute
because again i i feel that it the way
out of worlds does the companion
interaction
you know it is so well done because
again if they don't agree or one of them
feels strongly they will interject into
this situation
you know that's how i pick my people
when i'm leaving when i'm getting off
the ship i'm like i don't know man
you are a problem
yeah what's funny is uh me me and cog
we like to to little argue on who we
want to have because
i'm a huge ellie fan well i got to have
the chip with to be everywhere because
she always be saying
the craziest stuff
like it's like there was a time in this
dlc where
you know something happened and you know
one of the like one of the things you
could choose is like
am i the only one getting tired of
hearing the student's voice and at least
like i've been tired of hearing this tv
yeah there's a couple of scenes like
that there for sure you could do make
some funny things
so let's let's focus obviously on um
murder on eridanos again
you offer paralegal this is the new
thing you got this who done it feel
um question whose idea was it about the
whole
this discrepancy amplifier which is
literally like this detective device
that has its own personality
thing like tell me about including that
into the pretty sure that was megan
no i was gonna say it's joint because
you're the one who was like we have to
have a
magnifying glass and all that yeah so he
was like very pushing like that idea of
like a detective tool
and then once we were making it i was
like and it must have a funny
personality so yeah i'd say it's joint
but
i i kind of remember how you push for
that because i know we needed some
some more gameplay like this is one of
the things people who played outer
worlds we're hoping from the dlc like
just give us something that's kind of
slightly new and
yes and feels a little bit different so
we were playing around with this um
discrepancy amplifier idea i think
it was megan that said like can it just
just you just we have the technology to
scope right like you can aim through a
scope so let's just
retrofit that into like a thing that
lets you look around in the world
and somehow somehow that was enough like
that just kind of pull it off
it was awesome yeah i learned real quick
when i was doing that expansion
i was like oh i got to have my medical
up i got to have my perspective
constantly asking me for checks on
though
yeah you got to play with your
intelligence all the way down
that is my favorite back from back from
my fallout days man my intelligence is
always out of 10. it don't matter what
game it is
awesome it's so cool and um another
thing what i love about
eridanos is that just as dnc general and
the structure of our worlds it's um
i think natalie you mention it which is
you know i personally you know i have
like open world game fatigue
and as soon as i open up a map and i see
like a thousand icons
and all this other stuff so to me ottawa
is refreshing because it's like okay i'm
gonna be in this space or this hub so to
speak
but it's dense and then what i do
affects
the game like more so i feel so it's
like you know was that a conscious
decision as far as you know
as far as even writing does that that
kind of a
setup and structure uh help you guys
writing wise
as opposed to like having this huge map
kind of he's i guess
i'll tell you right now open world open
world anything to do it well is is super
difficult because
open world is really just one massive
massive level
uh and and we we have talented level
designers and artists too and if we told
them hey we're making an
open world and it's going to be highly
reactive to anything they might just
explode like that's like
my resumes i ain't doing this again
one of the nice things about having not
really hubs but like
self-contained kind of carefully
designed levels
is that we can we can define what the
story experience in that area is
right and and because we give ourselves
those boundaries we say okay
murder on aerodynamics takes place in
these areas and that's pretty much
it then we can do more in those areas
like if we just opened it up and made it
like a big ghost of tsushima
sort of thing it would actually be
harder to make
um believable interesting reactive role
play choices it would be harder to make
the world change
right because it's just so big because
the arena itself is smaller
you get a better experience i think well
i mean it pays off
yeah and what i like me and me incognito
was actually on a podcast with acg and
we were talking about like
the dis the choices you guys would win
without a world like
there's just one point in time uh in the
base game where uh they gave you the
option to go to a place that was like
the unsafe landing code they're like
you're looking at those like
man i'm good and you're glad that you
realize like
real quick i'm not good
[Laughter]
yeah again just it's just tremendous
writing i love this stuff i got a
question shout out to my boy uh daniel
may from lords of gaming.net he has some
questions in reference to
um the the the dumb dialogue lines
specifically
of like how's the process for that and
then on the other thing is
you know which specific characters
you both had the most fun
writing
go for the dumb stuff i was like
we had like a contest at work where
everyone submits their favorite dumb
line that they wrote in the base game
and he won the award and i think it was
like the dumbest dialogue
oh that's that's my title now
you are the dumb dialogue
look i i watched a lot of simpsons in
that's where the dumb comes from it's
it's basically captain homer simpson
okay captain home or something oh my god
was it difficult for you guys to
maintain that that satirical
comedy like oh it's kind of overarching
sort of
sort of uh tone for the whole game like
or did you guys have different ideas
about what
you know what that entailed or was it
everybody sort of on the same page about
the type of comedy we're gonna include
in the game
we do make everybody who joins the team
look at our
um you know influences our touchstones
specifically for
like humor and tone and different things
like that so
everybody had to watch the movie brazil
um
watch like yeah futurama and simpsons um
what were some of the other ones uh
firefly was big one
um i think for our dlc i was also
added you know like clue and knives out
and
agatha christie movies or books um
and then uh mandalorian since it was
more recent
that's a good one any gaming influences
you guys look to because i looked at
the characters and i'm like this feels
very gta-ish right the characters
that all of gta is is very much a satire
so i was like
this feels like that you know what's
funny is i feel like certain games
in our game we didn't so we didn't so
much as uh as be inspired by them but we
probably looked the same inspiration
like i know
leonard and tim really really like the
coen brothers right
one of the touchdowns for the coen
brothers style of storytelling
is absurdity you take something
completely ridiculous
and you have people treat it as it's an
everyday thing and you take
an everyday thing and you have people
treat it in the most ridiculous
ways
specifically when we'll i'm not going to
spoil but
the little passage yes that is
i know what i'm talking about
that was hilarious that's kind of how we
how we
keep ourselves from going to over the
top right like you would think that it's
so colorful and there's so much humor is
just going to turn silly and ridiculous
but
we have to balance silly with sirius
right like yes
very funny very stupid things happen to
people but these are also people who are
kind of living their lives in a horrible
system
and if you if you look around outer
worlds and you look around aerodynamics
you'll see a lot of them are
unhappy and they're not admitting it
maybe they're being um exploited at
their workplace like like things that
are very not
funny are right up against things that
are that are very funny
so that's kind of like the secret to our
balancing act i think
and i have to give you guys because you
cannot say lord i'm a very serious tone
person like
i've dropped games that aren't serious
toad i'm like
i'm like i don't care anymore but it's
just like for some
like the outer worlds had the moments
are like daniel that's ridiculous but it
never
it never went over the top rob like yeah
uninstall like
it was always like right but right
before i felt like it was getting out of
touch it's like you guys just took like
a rope was okay it's a little too much
it's getting right back on the left
yeah and i think that's that's extremely
hard to do because
it's normally people go off the top like
south park
or they go like real dark it is just
like you guys found that middle area
that i don't think a lot of people can
do
like yeah for sure i think the weapon
design in the game
is some of the best yeah like get a new
gun
and the first thing i do is go to my
inventory and i
always match it up against the next gun
you just see well let me just try it out
first i just had to keep it yeah i loved
it oh yeah
okay i got an addict i'm sorry the the
gun weapons you can ask cognito i was in
a party with him like two weeks ago
playing the
expansion i was like man because i when
i play expansions i like to start the
whole game over again
i'm like i need a shock weapon man
because these robots are kicking me man
i try not to say anything too much
because i don't want to give away stuff
i
always run with the robot i love running
yeah he likes to interject himself into
certain stuff
[Laughter]
anything melee anything you can pick up
and bash over somebody's head
um when you do tactical time dilation
with that sort of stuff it's like
it's hilarious for me it's totally
hilarious um
yeah i think you know obviously coming
from
you know seeing something like fallout
new vegas and fallout 3 or whatever
coming from that
to see what what was it that you guys in
terms of the combat what
what were the sort of the pillars of you
creating your combat
was it something that kind of like you
focused on okay this has to be
has to be smoother as a shooting
experience or that or
that wasn't sort of a big deal that's a
good question
i was not on the combat team um
yeah no i'm sorry i
i don't really so i'm not 100 sure how
to answer that
but i know i know that one of the
touchstones for
the game itself and included combat as
well is to have choices
right so so we didn't want to create a
situation where
uh you just you had to use handguns or
rifles like
we basically wanted you to have the
option to play
as much as possible the kind of
character you wanted to make so
so it comes from a place of let's let
you role play the fantasy
and if you just want to be a big dumb
brute who swings around his hospital
stick we're like okay
we support that yeah that's true yeah
that's the only place through i ain't
done on outer worlds
i don't know i just like the snipers in
the game i like you i like slow and tied
down getting that headshot
cause it's like by the time they get to
me i've already killed them
[Laughter]
i wanted to get back to the to again
cause you guys have great companions
and these great bam like bombastic kind
of like what were some of
your two favorites like yeah right
you're dying to know that
megan you can start like what what was
some of the favorite let's start with
let's start with companions first
um uh so each writer basically got a
companion
okay um yeah so i wrote sam and then i
helped leonard write picker max because
he was pretty busy
um and yeah i don't know it was
interesting because both of those were
um
you know preconceived of like hey here's
the concept they knew that they wanted
a um janitor robot companion but that
was essentially it
um originally it was just gonna have
kind of interfacing type lines like wash
mode
on and i thought it would be really
funny if we added the like well what if
they hired someone to do
all of their like recording in a studio
like he has like imagine
he's got you know a bunch of records and
he can just like put him on
the player and so he's got pre
pre-recorded things he can say that are
very commercialized and so that mix kind
of came together and i thought
that worked really well um and then with
uh bickermax
all of the like really smart
philosophical stuff
leonard's like genius mind and then i
did all the like low brow like
you know say hello to my little friend
type moments
yeah and then he's always talking about
going to prison and i think leonard
okay you know there's more to him than
just his prison i'm like but that's the
most
interesting thing i look like this is
the most
corrupt priest
and his friend yeah yeah the remains of
his friend
and then oh sorry go ahead i was gonna
say the crazy part that i
when i remember first playing it is like
because normally in these type of games
it takes a minute to get a couple
companions
but it's like you guys gave you guys
gave us the preacher and the mechanic
like right off the bat and i was like oh
that's cool party yeah
whoever the voice actress as well as the
writing excellent character one of the
fans you see a lot i see a lot of out of
worlds fans
she's up there on the list so salute to
whoever was responsible i don't know who
that was but
the the other question megan again so we
did the companion part
now specifically with murder on
eridano's
any specific um characters or moments
you don't want to spoil it as much as
you can you know we don't want you to
spoil but that really resonate with you
personally
um well i actually do really like that
as a dumb player you can accuse yourself
which was an entire idea
when you do it you like say it was me
blah blah blah and not only is
the administrator who hired to be like
oh my god literally every single
companion like all of your companions
are in the room and they all chime in
and are just like this is the worst
moment of my life like
following this guy i just kept going and
going and going and i was like dying
laughing but anyways
you know would have been funny if you
had like that was like a secret ending
where you could throw in his job
play again to the title same two
questions eddie's
favorite companion or one that you
involved with that you really liked as
well as
your favorite moment you know murder
you're really going to make me pick a
companion
one of the one of the ways we design the
companions is like all right we need all
our companions to be different enough
that everybody's going to like something
about them like they they all have
contrasting personalities
so i wrote felix so i'm always going to
have a soft spot for like felix's
moments
um but like i i really like uh parvati i
think i think she's amazing um ashley
burch's voice acting was so so good the
best
if you if you take parvati with you when
you uh grill
bertie holcomb oh my god
that was what i took she was amazing i
like having
ellie because that was with my two
people because like they're literally
the opposites it feels like
so here's the thing is that i have so
many like favorite moments with command
i think like ellie's moment with her
parents is one of them
that was i think that was kerry patel
who wrote that it was just it was so
good it's
so funny it's got this like super dry
really dead pen and absolutely hilarious
like nyoka story about um her losing her
friends is really good
um i i'd have to say my personal
favorite companion has got to be sam
because i'm just again it's that it's
those futurama roots i just
love a mouthy robot who says the
stupidest things that's
the best there's a moment in the base
game where if you play a dumb character
and you talk to sophia akande about
like her plan of what to do with the
colony you can be like hang on
i gotta ask all my companions and you
turn directly to your robot he's like
well i i think you should buy more
cleating solutions
oh my god
i love him i take him all over the place
absolutely kind of a grounded question
um
obviously you know we're in a pandemic
game development
is different so what what challenges
you know did you guys have you know i'm
assuming you know
creating this dlc during these
circumstances how different and
difficult
was it for you guys
oh yeah yeah go ahead oh sure i can go
um
yeah the pandemic's been tough for game
dev uh it is tough for us it's tough for
everybody
um in a lot of ways i think the biggest
challenge is that
for a lot of people like going from an
office
immediately to working from home there's
really no
physical separation between the place
you work and the place you live
and uh game dev the amount of work that
goes into game dev it's very easy
for those boundaries to just kind of
dissolve where you just find yourself
working later because you're already in
your bedroom or you're already in your
living room or something like that um i
i know like a lot of our
designers pushed hard to get this out
the door you know as a labor of love
to the fans but doing that out of
quarantine is exhausting and 2020 was
was a rough year to put it as an
understatement i i know that um
voice acting was also super difficult
like we had to we had to remotely
record every single actor uh so we had
like this deconstructed studio
where the um the audio guys were
up in canada and we had an actor over in
la and
it was i don't know how it got done yeah
it is a small miracle
that um this dlc came out
uh with the quality of voice acting that
it did yes um
because i just i have no idea how it got
done having uh voice actors all over the
world
well we wanted um allegra clark for
halcyon helen's voice and she's very in
demand so her schedule was super tight
and then the time that we had to record
was pretty tight
and then um one of her friends or
co-workers i think accidentally exposed
her to covid so she had a quarantine for
two weeks so we were like
super nervous about like oh my gosh are
we going to be able to record with her
are we going to have to try and find
somebody else
last minute um so it worked out but it
was a little hectic
with certain things like that um i think
for the internal team it was actually
pretty smooth because we just
went into the office got our computers
brought them home and then
we just do this you know we already we
would you know talk on
i am slack all day and then you know you
don't get to like turn around
and just immediately be able to ask
someone who sits behind you or you know
walk down the hall and knock on their
door but
it's pretty easy to just message them
and be like hey can you hop on a quick
call
um and video chat um also
slightly unrelated but i was kind of
thinking about it when we were talking
about
the whole like pitching and working with
publishers and stuff like that i did
just want to clarify
um private division was super awesome to
work with like i have worked with
different publishers for different games
and different studios and they
like were super like in tune to what we
were trying to do and very supportive
and like they're just all around awesome
but then also i feel like the process
with being um you know a bid studio and
having to
pitch to different publishers is
completely different than actually being
microsoft owned
like microsoft was like we bought you as
a studio because we
value the games that you make and you're
interested to just see what type of
games you'll make
so as far as i know we've not had to do
anything like that as a microsoft studio
it's just like
um hey all of our projects are funded
because we have a studio budget
and we're good every year so that's been
like a huge relief
um at least for me as like a normal you
know bottom level developer
and i think it felt extra stable during
the pandemic of like we were able to
bring our equipment home and keep
working and like nothing really changed
whereas like if we were how we were
before if we were like hey we're trying
to spin up a new project and we have to
try and get funding for it it would have
been a lot more stressful during the
pandemic for sure
yeah that was one of my biggest
questions uh what was it like
after the acquisition and um how was it
received by the team and
you expressed relief um so
uh that that was that was i was going in
there i was going into that
okay yeah for me it was like
it was super awesome because one the
studio is then
financially stable and then also able to
like make the type of projects that
they've wanted to do like it enabled
them to do like grounded
and a project that josh lawyer is
working on right now that project
and grounded is super successful yeah
anything
and had you had to pitch that you know
to
uh somebody else i don't think that it
would have had the life
but the fact that it was also listen i'm
captain game passes
game pass and it allowed people because
you know people was really skeptical
when they were saying that it was a
kitty game and all this other stuff and
but when you get a chance to touch it
and get a chance to
play it it opens you up to different
things and
now that i'm seeing this especially
during this pandemic time and
financially
people don't have the finances to go out
and try
different experiences um
i see this as a boom for uh
developers in gaming when i
purchase um out of worlds and then
i automatically got the season pass you
know
oh yeah it didn't feel like we yeah yeah
because you're like you're
investing back into the company right
and also i purchased the game regardless
but it it allowed me to try it i loved
it i wanted more
and i said oh they're coming out with
dlc i purchased it have you seen that as
a reaction
that most of the people that purchased
the game or played the game
actually went out to uh get the blc with
pearl negan america like are you guys
seeing
any type of engagement there but
definitely no i i that's exactly like
this is a story we hear a lot it's like
well i saw outer worlds on game pass i
tried it i loved it so much i decided to
just go and buy it to support you guys
like
like this is the thing that that we know
because we play games too and we're part
of this community too but it's sometimes
it's harder to communicate up to the
highest level is that
people who play games will happily
support a developer
who puts in work and gives them
something that they love they will 100
do that um and one of the nice things
just to echo what megan said about
um working with private division working
with microsoft is not only do they
get the kind of games that obsidian is
good at making but they just kind of
like
support us with hands off you know like
we we've been doing this for a long long
time
and they're they haven't come in and
said okay we own you now make the kind
of games
they act like the board
and i'm glad that you said that because
it's a huge fear
in well in certain parts of our toxic
community
that was saying oh once microsoft uh
purchases them they will no longer be
the same they won't have a soul
and it's great to hear that you guys are
able to work on projects that you love
and you're doing this stuff without the
overarching
you know dark cloud on top of you and
it's been a totally different experience
um could you elaborate a little bit more
on that part because i mean
sure so i here's the thing is i get it
change scares people and we have seen so
many situations where
a really big publishing corporation
comes in takes over
and the game that you used to love is
just not
the same thing anymore like like it's
it's happened so many times that i don't
necessarily blame people
for being a little bit gun shy about
that um the
the idea that oh it's not the same
obsidian well
it isn't because we're stable now
we can we can like experiment more and
we can really put ourselves out there
without necessarily having to worry
about
hey are we going to be financially
stable at the end of this project like
that is that's the good kind of growth
that you do want to see in the industry
so i'm
i'm really happy about the microsoft
acquisition i'm happy about
private division support they've exactly
been fantastic from start to finish yeah
to the team and i'm sorry sorry you want
to jump in there no okay yeah
you know just salute because at the end
of the day you know as for game dev you
know
that has to be a piece of mind that that
security okay we could do what we want
to do and then
again megan great points in reference to
an entire reference to the uh
you know the conditions it working
during the pandemic how things change
and you guys still
put out arguably a lot of community the
realm says
murder and rodonos is that one you know
as far as dlc no disrespect to pearl or
gold guaranteed we liked it we did like
it
but like to to have it it did give me
one of my favorite guns
yeah yes yes i killed the boss from uh
from the second expansion with the uh
the gun from the chick for the first
experiment
it's just cool to see and the future
looks bright you know obviously
you guys are one of our favorite uh xbox
game studios and i guess with the
private division again with initially
supporting the vision in the very
beginning
to get it up off the ground and believe
in you guys so just like
the culture i just conclude like you
know excited for the future and
obviously this game was received well
you know so um
you know i don't want to get nobody in
trouble but we would love
for that we would love to see this thing
continue
you know what are your thoughts ladies
and gentlemen
too much trouble my lips are sealed
okay okay so but i would ask this
in reference to the future um do you
guys
as as narrative creators is there
anything you've seen
on the tech side that that makes
it's really exciting for you in terms of
what you can do narratively in a game
like we've heard about things that
you know improvements in ai and stuff
like that to sort of make the world more
reactive and
and and grounded and real as narrative
creators does that sort of stuff excite
you have you seen anything already just
in whatever
it is that you're working on now that
sort of pushes those boundaries in a way
that you haven't been able to do before
i know i'm like we should well we do
have so i think
uh i could be biased but um having
worked at different studios
i actually think that obsidian has one
of the most robust um
writing and you know vo type tool set
um in the industry um to the point where
other xbox studios are actually like
requesting access to it and looking for
cloud and so like that and we've been
meeting with some
teams won't mention any names that are
working on very cool projects
um to teach them like how to get the
most out of the tool set and we have a
dedicated tools team that has been
supporting that pretty much since the
start of the studio so a very long time
has gone into that on the flip side we
then get to
say like hey what is an area that we
would like to improve on in our next
game and then um reach out to a studio
and say hey you know we thought that
your ai or
you know how you handled your animations
were really cool could be
look at some of your stuff so that's
really nice
that pushes the whole engine up like you
know the fact that you guys have access
to a network
it will make the whole engine better
my next question was the fact that there
are so many development studios i
believe you're at 23 to 26 now
um
it's one of the other one or the other
next
um the fact that uh
you guys have those development teams
and you're able to have that pipeline to
reach over
to acts uh other developers um
i saw this and uh could we use this
that happens between you guys as
frequently as we would hope
that's the question i have oh okay so i
will say um
there's not and i i know this is
something that or i was told at least
um that there's no like mandate from
microsoft that's like oh
everybody needs to use the same tool
sets because they don't want the games
to feel too samey
right so it's very um organic like they
encourage it but it has to be like one
studio
has to say actually we thought that you
know what this game did was really cool
and then reach out to them directly
it is really really easy for us to get
in touch with each other and
microsoft does do like summits like i
just went to a franchise summit and they
have narrative summit um
coming up where you know people from
every studio they send
anyone who's interested and then you can
all get together and
you know share lessons you've learned or
things you're struggling with or
you know talk about your tool sets and
your processes and so that's really cool
that is awesome i mean super refreshing
i'll let you go so i just
got to get solved absolutely because you
know again the
the mindset the the the twitter verse is
again the evil board of microsoft's come
in
and you know you guys are gonna be
worried no one can do anything and
to hear you guys say you know that
the collaboration is encouraged between
other
studios and hey what i love what you
said megan is with
you know the gods of obsidian that
narrative they they had to lean
on one of the best
studios
[Laughter]
that wealth of narrative knowledge but
what's cool is
you know as a team you all say hey you
know we may need to improve here or we
like
what you guys did with ai here or so and
just to see that synergy within xbox
game studios is
really refreshing to hear i'll give it
to solve it that will
wrap up with time soon get at it solve
it i do have a question that someone
asked in the chat that i thought was
interesting
uh uh what are all both of you
uh what is your favorite companion to
companion dialogue
because i thought that was an
interesting question i really like
um felix and vicar max because like
there's a bunch of ones where felix is
like hey vic can i call you vic and he's
like no
and there's one where like i think felix
got drunk and stumbled into max's room
at like two in the morning and
it's like you know i'll take your
confession any time but not then or
something
i really like felix and parvati i think
i think they're they're very sweet in a
kind of silly way like yes
felix has this has this thing where he's
trying to explain
toss ball to parvati in public yeah okay
i don't understand this at all okay so
the thing about toss ball is that
internally as a studio none of us know
how it works
there's a 30 second back and like you
can you can make
you can like score in the third half
it's just complete nonsense
sounds like friday night yeah
any other questions i want to wrap up
yeah yeah really really quick
is there a big difference between making
a crpg type game like pillars
and something like you know first person
like like out of worlds or
or is it kind of the same process
some of the big differences are how the
player moves through the map for the
world so like in crpg it's going to be a
lot more
linear like you might have a couple of
entrances and exits but you know you
move like across
um whereas you know open world space
it's like the player can go in almost
any order
talk to people in any way um
and so i think there is a lot more
reactivity or
edge cases that you have to build for
yeah
okay and curiosity which ones do you
guys prefer to
develop for the one they just did yeah
i'm just i'm just curious because some
people some people like the pillars
there are different types of games um i
think i think the uh
the first person outer world style of
game is it has a much wider reach
like pretty much anybody like we all
know what an fps is we all know how to
get into it
it's more immersive i think because it's
an fps um
i i do like the isometric stuff i enjoy
divinity original sin two i enjoy
pillars
because like my roots are d and and when
i play those games
what i want is to feel like i'm sitting
at a dnd table with a really cool game
master like
that's it's a it's a very different
experience but it's still a good one
it does film our pen and paper yeah you
know not to
divert too much but it is a nice
experience like because i remember when
i would play like the divinity like you
you
you're going over everything with people
he's like okay i'm gonna teleport this
dude up here
you're gonna hit him up here we're gonna
finish him and then before you know five
minutes like everyone's dead so it's
like that wasn't
the right man so look we got a wrap we
got our esteemed guest at their limit so
we have to ask the question that we ask
all the lords and ladies in the realm i
need from both of you
lady megan lord and ty what are your top
five video games or
franchises of all time
let's start with uh lord the tie first
oh man i'm gonna put me on the spot
i was gonna make you go first too
my number one is street fighter when i
when i was when i was six years old
my neighbor had a super nintendo and he
had street fighter 2 and it was the
first game i've ever played i'm a huge
fgc fan i will be
until i'm 60 years old i'm also a final
fantasy fan i just this is again
something i grew up with
okay oh here we go
your favorite final fantasy sir i am
completely in love with final fantasy 14
lately
okay he's the mmo head okay
i think my favorite of all time has to
be six yeah
it's so beautiful and it's so good we're
just gonna stop at the 14.
okay you're doing so well lord no no no
pretty good pretty good let's go i'd
like the seven remake i thought it was
funny all right all right
number three is probably dungeons and
dragons again just something i grew up
with something
that's been with me for a long time yes
um
i i'm really in love with shadow of the
colossus just
it's the only game i've ever i've ever
played where narrative design
enemy design and level design are
exactly the same thing like
that's pretty much such a good one yeah
i uh what is my number five i
i uh i'm stuck here
you know oh wait i know exactly what my
number five is it is a franchise that's
near and dear to my heart that i missed
because i don't think it's been done
well for a really long time but it's
dynasty warriors
oh i like to play that game i like that
i had it i had to toss that in the
bushes too
have you ever played the dynasty
warriors fighting game the original
dynasty warriors
playstation one i i have not but i know
about it i think
like i really miss four and five and i
i just i wish sony would just take those
games and make them available to play
at some point but they don't seem to
want to do that i thought i saw the
trailer for the new one it looked really
good yeah you know
you said something that i i definitely
it is probably a lot different for a dev
playing games like
they just look at how they do that like
i i that is probably a huge difference
from like someone that don't know
anything about development
knows development cycle play of the game
no doubt so let's get lady
megan her top five video games or
franchises of all time
okay um i think i've mentioned these a
lot but and also if you play
the dlc i think you'll see the
influences in it but my top
ones of all time are um bioshock
fallout borderlands witcher 3 and portal
oh yeah and i think one time like a guy
told me like those are all the same game
and i was like oh wait well i guess i'm
a type for my favorite
curiosity the major question yeah i
don't know
i'm gonna get it at a curiosity which
fallout
no no i like both of them equally but
the first one that i played was fallout
3 and so i think just that first
experience of it
it's like will always hold a special
place in my heart and then obviously new
vegas is awesome
so that's right yeah hey notice she
didn't say four i just wanted
to hey to king's question like you said
yes
both here you go for any generation
favorite console and why start
loading the tie first oh my god
any generation they thought it was over
thought it was
it's not over i this is this is i don't
i don't talk about this a lot because
nobody really talks about this console
anymore but i
when i was when i was young i really
really love the sega saturn
thank you very much
for the kids when we were young there
was a rivalry between
sega and playstation and for a very long
time they went head-to-head
i still think the dreamcast is a
seriously underrated console that died
way too early it had its own built-in
56k
you could play fantasy star online like
it was doing things
that nobody else ever did and then it
just died i think it's i think it is a
huge
it's a huge loss to just gaming that
that entire generation of console kind
of faded into obscurity
you know saddened i mean
[Music]
thank you yes yes
[Laughter]
did you see there's like a netflix
documentary about
old um gaming well it might not have
been just about that but included um
sega
they're like how they shot so like
payment yeah it was really good
and how they imploded afterwards
because it was two it was two companies
yeah but okay
lady megan you're your favorite council
of all time any generation and why
well i think mine is like split because
um when i was growing up
we had um uh super nintendo
in our house but it was only because my
dad played games and so
the only games we had for were like
desert strike and
um uh like wrestling
and those type of like oh and um uh
oh man my brain just flipped out good
you're good
you're good the the nazi one
nazis oh yeah yeah yeah yeah why did my
brain like yes wolfenstein i was like
um but yeah so i grew up on those type
of games and then watching my dad play
doom
on the computer and then when i went off
to college
i bought myself a playstation 3 and
i remember like uncharted kind of came
with it and it was the first time i saw
like wow look at how video games look
now like
back then it would like give you
headaches if you played it for too long
because it was like so sharp and bright
so yeah i think for me it was like a
huge
jump between uh what i had experienced
i'm gonna force you to pick one now you
you had you i know
you have one playstation three
no it's probably the super nintendo okay
thank you
oh
[Music]
obsidian entertainment an absolute
pleasure to have
both of you in the room where can the
fine people find you
and what else do you have going on let's
start with lord the tai first
uh unfortunately you guys can't find me
anywhere
invite me back again that's nice
absolutely brother absolutely i
love your insight i love what you guys
do at other team
tremendous tremendous we we we are super
excited for the future
and you know what what we try to like
really
pray chairs is like look like just
because some games might come out buggy
not saying out of worlds dude it's like
there's still developers behind these
and
they still have emotions it's like you
can give constructive criticism about
doing the two-hour podcast
like destroying the game for no reason
exactly salute we love we
total appreciation for what you guys are
doing and of course lady
megan who is on social media where can
the popular find you
and what else do you have going on oh
i'm on twitter
uh my handle is uh fictivate uh which is
he already put it in the chat yay yeah
it just means
made up word means to make fiction
basically um
and uh so what do i have going on uh
hobby wise
i did put out an urban fantasy novel um
20 late 2019 called house of ash and
brimstone
um it's really cool it's kind of like a
buffy
type influence on it um and i did take a
break on
writing novels when um obsidian asked me
to be a game director
on the dlc just because it's a lot of
work and
um pandemic was pretty crazy too so now
that all that's wrapped up i'm gonna try
and get back into it
absolute pleasure again continue the
great work the lords of obsidian
greatness is in the building salute the
private division salute the xbox game
studio
this is tremendous thank you guys so
much thank you
super informative yeah it was really fun
thank you
you had a great time thank you yeah it's
like
you know we were single pouring on the
show uh
especially being incognito like we
always said man we got to get upset yeah
we've been doing this
that we get a little bit more grace you
know when you guys got bought by
microsoft i was like
there it is
this is my shot but still it did take a
couple
years even after that happened yeah but
we're so humble
so everybody enjoy your day thank you so
much we're gonna continue reveling on
talking on our show
but i wanted to give you guys the proper
outro and enjoy your day thank you again
the
obsidian entertainment xbox game studios
private division salute
have a good way have a blessed day put
those links in the chat
try it again hustle no doubt no doubt i
will get
poll and all that other stuff as we
continue blah blah blah
one second did we go do that how are you
gonna head to our super chats how you
just do this yeah okay
um so we got the ever born saga five
five dollar super chat uh the lords are
in the building bx stand up i
read these already hold on uh we got
slow-mo back slap five dollar super chat
afternoon ladies and gentlemen and
abbott
glad to see obsidian in the room one of
the best uh
wrpg devs can't wait for outer worlds
too we gotta we gotta on that one so
we'll see
then we've got domikin 89 with the five
dollar superchat can we expect another
fallout from obsidian
uh love you guys keep up the good work
that's one of the reasons we waited
until after that
yes yes the nba questions are coming
exactly then we had to get them out so
they didn't have to deal with that
then we've got sage with the twenty
dollars if you chat let it be known that
i personally find obsidian to be one of
the best game developers on the planet
south park stick of truth is one of my
all-time favorite video games and rpgs
so well done so creative love you guys
you all forgot about south park wow
yeah they didn't specifically work on
that but
well i mean i don't know are they still
in the chat i still hear megan oh yeah
sorry was i supposed to leave you're
like
look we out of respect
did you work on this no no i didn't work
on south park
um but some of the people like um
i think our combat lead combat designer
charles staples he was on it
um a bunch of the people at the studio
have just rolled from
project project like when i started on
tyranny my
boss um matt mclean was uh so basically
i was telling him oh my god you know my
favorite in
new vegas was caesar's legion he was
just like oh yeah i wrote that and i was
like
it's weird to be like all these games
that you love all of a sudden the people
who made them are just like your normal
co-workers is
weird yeah absolutely then we have east
texas alex with the five dollars
hello everyone uh just doing support
i'll be checking out the show tomorrow
at work have a great show thank you man
then we have gamers play with the five
dollar super chat shout out to the devs
of obsidian
outerworlds is my my fifth favorite open
world rpg
great characters and humor as well love
to the iron lords for hosting salute
yes then we have dodge treatment with
the five dollar super chat
yo can i get a t tlc tv
favorite podcast audio only listener
just dropping off some love
peace all right r.i.p station
[Laughter]
i don't know what you're talking about
i've never seen this sort of discourse
you know we're not super chats
um we have brett bingham two dollars
super chat your favorite companion to
comparing dialogues i think that's the
one
addict read before big cloud gaming with
the five dollars to be chat almost 500
people here let's go
get to 400 likes salute to the brothers
iron lords podcast
thank you brother appreciate it bro then
we have lord brat
with the two dollars chat absolute lords
thank you my brother
then we have kids move with the ten
dollar super chat
i paired per body i don't know about per
body i don't know a character
that's another character
uh with vicar for 80 of my playthrough
um y'all did an amazing job with pavardi
she got me through many scenarios with
ease 2019 game of the year good job
i can't get i can't get pervading out of
my head now yeah
we have aaron with the five dollars from
chat how does it feel being sister
studios to bethesda
zenimax please i need to know
what's the question okay how does it
feel to be the sister studio to bethesda
slash zenimax please
i need to know i think it's super cool i
can't wait to see them at like the
summits that we do because i'm a huge
fan of their games
and uh one time i think i got to go to
one of their parties and i was like
really starry-eyed so
i'm that person is like bugging them and
they're like hey hey
we'll see that we have also the motivate
five dollars we checked the dreamcast
walked so the xbox could run great
interview guys lady megan said the snes
was her favorite so she's lit
that was that tie yeah oh yeah oh no
sorry sorry sorry super nintendo yeah i
don't know why
i need another cup of coffee
now hold on we have brett bingham once
again with the five dollar super chat
microsoft and sony fighting over square
enix like peter and the chicken from
family guy
not really there's no fight one person
has money and another person doesn't
oh my gosh then we have gerald mack five
dollar super chat
shout out to the ilp here on vacation in
vegas but it's still the lord's day
great show great guests one love thank
you so much
thank you having all your fun and you
tuned in i love you
then we have sage once again with the
five dollar super chat i behaved myself
today because of the fantastic obsidian
guests
i'm still in twitter jail doing my time
your podcast is my yard time
from twitter yes cause he added me to a
group and he apologized
that he added me to the group thank you
for apologizing
i would ask you to tell me what you did
on twitter but you can't because you're
curious
you can't tell it's really messy what
else you got uh
last but not least malik tyler with the
five dollar super chat r.i.p
playstation all hail lord spencer thank
you there you go
here we go okay
are you sure megan you're gonna stick
waiting i around
like oh okay well i don't want to like
just leave right now no
it's fine no no no no no no see the
thing is the thing is
it gets a little messy yeah i'm gonna
go make lunch
okay so we're caught up we're gonna be
messy okay
didn't want to go get too much into the
um the murder mystery because
yeah a lot of times you might say some
[Music]
there's a lot of jokes in there and then
i love taking a robot and the robot says
some weird stuff at so wild times
someone said we lost the queen to the
talks to chat
absolutely for even considering rocking
out that i was awesome that was
that was beautiful so let's get to the
poll when we get into these two topics
then uh get
pushing last week's poll results are in
and the people have spoken to the
question
with the latest bloomberg article
stating sony's focus on blockbuster
titles
how concerned are you with the overall
direction of sony moving forward
throughout the generation the winner at
a commanding
72 percent of the vote was very
concerned
leadership is money chasing and losing
the identity of the sony brand
coming in at second at 18 kings laughing
of the vote was the messi lords
i don't care until it's tv tv and they
start remaking more remix
and that last place and only the
opposite of the vote was i am not
concerned sony is still the market
leader and with the best games
notice how y'all in last place
that market leader stuff changed as soon
as it started
so like i said new poll covered at the
end of the show let's get into these
topics couple quick
hitters lord attic you are up man we're
gonna talk about the c-bomb
what's the c-ball what's going on what's
going on but people playstation's dead
you want to do that
so
are we talking about are we talking
about the batteries that died like yeah
but i thought didn't the ps4 have the
same thing yes
so never died so we can continue so
check it out check it out what other
people did
so clearly wants to talk about this
check it out
because i found it really hilarious
right they they copied the same mistake
same dude that designed it is in charge
he made the same mistake
last time he did it right so right now
if your memory dies right the little
cmos
the little seabed the little round one
yeah if it died
you can't access none of your digital
stuff so whatever you brought digitally
oh
right but you can't play physical either
so it's not replaceable nah i don't
think it's from understanding it it
won't have the memory
that's crazy you could put it in but it
is i mean you could literally like on
the sega side and you could literally
replace that you know
but not ditto
[Laughter]
i just found it funny let's go that's
all i just wanna i just wanna
shake it i'm gonna go let me get it let
me get this super test real quick we got
post up five dollar super chat game pass
gang you either jump in the ring or you
get under the wing
great show yeah look at that full stop
salute absolutely then we got
max the lazy otaku two dollars super
chat glad king brought up the c
bomb baddest l on yo it's crazy right
now
they got time limits on everything the
time limits on their controllers yeah
the time limits on the camera
everything's gotta motivate you could
replace it kegs
like your warranties will be up anyways
not if it's accelerated
what game franchise or franchises would
you like to see revived i have a few
area 51 nba ballers midnight club
midnight
i'm gonna say midnight club because i
don't care about any of that i don't
like cold stone i want power
oh my goodness oh no he that that was
his suggestions
yeah i want power i don't know what i
would like to see like
it it's kind of crazy like part of me
kind of wants to see them bring back the
the chrono trigger in that franchise but
like the other part of me is just like i
just want them to make other stuff like
this after uh streets of rage i want
golden eggs
oh wow that would be fantastic i want
golden eggs i
i want these games to to to be
like the graphics now and the animations
that we have now
like i'm really just went back to play
streets of rage because of this dlc
yeah so it's i don't know they doing uh
ninja turtles yeah so i mean come on
let's go let's bring him back
we caught up yeah we're good yeah so
pretty much since we stayed on the sony
topic um the other part of it i believe
to king's topic was also the uh the
april update so it looks like they had
another
update they sony now has the usb storage
option
available um i believe it's uh what is
it 250 gig
minimum with an eight terabyte capacity
and um
basically they says that i think two two
usb storage can't be connected at the
same time
but basically kind of like what the xbox
series x has which is that you have that
option to add a caddy but
yeah to kings news which i know he can't
wait to talk about
is as of right now there's still no um
the ssd option the empty yeah that's
close that's sloppy
get that slide that slide is not
available yeah they said it would be um
in a future
update they're going to date yeah
they'll let you know later
so kid clearly you want to talk about
this so what
you feel about the storage being closed
you
[Laughter]
microsoft told you you got proprietary
and it cost so much like calvin
yo they have no solution
literally lock them out and if you play
with it if you put something inside of
it
your system don't work don't shut off
that is yo
y'all been bamboozled and let it
straight
and right now all the stuff is coming to
pass
y'all just got an update that allowed
you to play with an
a regular a regular hard drive
yo they said okay yeah i suffered long
enough
here goes a regular hard drive
to the basics
i've been waiting for the day for y'all
to get the update and it came
but it wasn't the update you was looking
my god yo y'all can't just else the
elves that y'all are getting
is so hilarious no wonder y'all not on
my timeline
this is the best i just wanted to ask
the realm are you ready to put your hard
drive together
and you can't put two together it can't
know
if you put two it might blow up
out of that part it's kind of funny it
kicked it yeah i was surprised
when i did i did i have my console on
you know on rust mode right so
the update got pushed to the console
automatically but
then it turned my console off it didn't
go back into rest mode
so i turned the console i'm like oh no
no no tim dawg just tweeted something
oh wow what's up with that xbox sunday i
don't know if he's meeting like
sunday for their conference are you
talking about next sunday
yeah we'll figure it out so um so i
turned my console on right
and i thought it was doing the the the
repair thing i was like oh no
yeah the database and it and it wasn't
doing that but it was it was like a hard
restart i'm like why are you hard
why are you not just taking me back to
where i was and i had to go through that
initial setup again i'm like what kind
of update
is this it's just i don't know man it
just nothing feels smooth
on on on their back end parts um
i don't know man i don't know man i was
scared to death because i've been my
my console's been good and i thought for
a minute it was a rap practice
yeah no doubt um your playstation 5
owner
will you be utilizing the usb caddy
storage now
pretty much at this current oh and by
the way i will be live streaming dark
souls tomorrow
it'll be on this channel so you can come
there and complain that i don't like
hey look look let me let me rant for 15
seconds
why is people telling me that i'm like
okay man i was like i want to be fast
they're like so i picked this character
and then i start i start taking some
clothes off
because i'm like look i'd rather be
naked on demon souls
than rolling around like i weigh 800
pounds
right not about that you're not a [ __ ]
he took the helmet off first right so he
takes the helmet off
he goes that's not enough so he's out
there nipples out right
so he takes he takes the armor off and
he's rolling around
he says yeah i'm faster you know you you
got you got to be real king i was doing
better with clothes off
were you still playing with a dagger or
did you change up no no no no no no
i messed up that a couple tracks so
data the what about the ssd solution
like is it a situation where
you're frustrated that you won't be able
to get that just now or
is it something that when it's activated
would you even be interested in based on
how big these games are
no like to be honest with you guys
normally i only have like five or six
games
like i play i i usually have apex led
apex legends downloaded but as far as
like games i play
it's very few maybe two or three yeah
and
when i want to delete something it's
very apparent why he played this damn
game in six months so i just delete it
like i've never been the kind of person
like like
lord cog loves the um he loves the quick
resume on xbox
and it's cool but it's like to me it's
just like i'll go quick resume from the
only game i'm playing to the only game
i'm playing yeah yeah
it's just it's not just a joke no i feel
i'll jump in i mean
um yeah look you know the king's point
yes you know
you we were hoping that we would have an
answer by that so i can't i know king's
clown but
there's truth to it you know at the end
of the day you know
it's nice that we got a you know the
catty old school option finally you know
what i'm saying but at the end of the
day
i think my frustration king is just that
you know at least give us what the
minimum spec is going to be so
for this nvme that's going to be
compatible with playstation 5.
yeah because it overheats
you know and this is back to that
variable junk
uh juggling console that i was talking
about earlier
it overheats right this okay this is
the console's been out long enough right
you not to have a storage solution
that you already have the slot for
that's there
you know um it's not like nintendo where
they show
where you saw at the base of the docking
and you saw that thing in the back and
you didn't know exactly what that was
and we were booming it was
expansion bay for something right no
this is an actual
storage uh spot and they told you the
ssd solution can go there so you can
actually purchase
uh like a samsung ssd that can actually
fit in there
yeah but the questions is why haven't
they allowed it to be available
why aren't they answering the people's
questions this latest update told you
that there was a minimum spec for it and
a maximum spec
for it and then you weren't able to
double up on your um your hard drive
it's just certain things about this
console which seems like
it's like yeah we laughed at the price
of the of the xbox
uh expansion but i mean yeah i mean it's
helped so many people right and it is
the going
great when it comes to nvme yes tech
like we we
i know a lot like it's way overpriced
and trust me i was the one that had to
bring me and i didn't want to
buy it but at the end of the day when
you look at like i bought an mba
for my wig like that is comparable to
that
i'm having an addict what is he doing
oh he wants to jump in oh look at look
i do get annoyed when we get new
consoles and it's a downgrading from the
old consoles like in any way like
software wise like xbox one came out
oh my god it was it was literally a
shell compared to the xbox 360. like
literally a show
like it was so bad when the xbox one
originally came out
it didn't even tell you when your
friends were online yeah it was just
like you weren't it was hard
sometimes it's like it's changed for the
sake of change like the ui
stuff on the playstation that's that's
why you'll never hear me
saying oh we need a new eye for
everything if the ui is fine
it's fine you don't need to keep making
new stuff just because it's a new car
and i feel like one of the reasons that
xbox has had less hiccups when it comes
to software
is because they've been evolving their
ui to take it to next gen yeah and not
just like
bam there's the ui six months later make
slight adjustments bam there's the ui
and then like eight years later we're
gonna make a new ui
no i feel you guys so if you're gonna
say something i'll finish off
oh no i for me as playstation being
that box is for their exclusives and the
fact that my
internal hard drive is full already yeah
with not that many
games out it is very telling so i don't
i don't i don't really care for this
usb solution yeah cool i could download
ps5 games and transport them back and
forth
right but i just i want that internal
solution and the thing soft too is we
don't even think about i mean
none of us i don't believe here are ps5
digital owners right oh i am
i am oh i got two i got two games
like it that's the thing it's just like
at the end of the day like you know
these games these 4k assets these all
these
these are huge fill up in about two
three four five
what you know what i mean and i'm always
afraid again especially at the start of
a generation i'm i'm afraid to attach
external uh just normal external sort of
storage to
to this because you just never know how
it's going to react with the system
you know a system update could come and
and fix some things and then break other
things
right so i i want their solution
whatever their solution is
i don't think they figured it out they
haven't no i i i
don't think that would be either and if
if not necessarily haven't figured it
out
they're not like i feel like they
released the ps5
but it was still like software was still
being developed for
and i feel like
i think the console was functional
enough to put it out
but when it come to certain things
you're like yo that's on the back end
right
get to it but we ain't we ain't got to
yet
yeah it is interesting and i i i would
have to agree in a sense of
you know getting these systems out and
then you know not having the necessary
plan ready to go again
just not knowing what to spend it's just
i just want to know what the
ssd specs so i could look in that ring
so when i'm ready i'm like okay
this is the spec that it's compatible
you know the funny thing is
you know like just knowing them it'll be
some 500 dollars
it'll be the price of the console you
know what's crazy
is the fact that like i obviously i'm no
engineer to no degree
at all but it's like how how is it my
tablet can have external
uh support but but a ps5 can't
when that's when that first launch you
couldn't even hook up an external
hard drive to it it might work what was
it what was it thursday
[Music]
[Laughter]
but my point is that much
like how do you drop the ball where you
can't even do something
that that hardware has been doing for
years
well that's when you take for granted
your uh
your populace your fan base
and they you feel that they're going to
take whatever you give them
when when you can say to them yeah we're
going to give you a controller that's
going to die in 400 hours
and we got a console with cmos that's
going to blow up on you later on that
you ain't
able to access anything digital or
physical and
this is the stuff we were worrying about
right with all this hot new stuff that
you know the first week of the
playstation police so
you know the press that had it earlier
were talking about the the the
the next gen features everything and
yeah the thing is look i heard now that
you know mlb the show doesn't have
a lot of a lot of uh sort of uh
controller functionality
nah not really that i'm hearing it's not
really you can't blow into the
controller make the ball fly
i guess not to to be honest with you
guys though like
i see the potential of the controller i
really enjoyed playing
it but it is it was a very it was a very
you know that's all that it is but at
the same time it's like
i know that astrobots devs are the only
people doing this
right but that's how sony has always
done remember that that what was that
hulk game
fire hawk or something like that skyhawk
uh warhawk warhawk
and you was able to use the six axes
yeah
remember remember lair you remember
it was that it was lyr and it was um
heavenly blade heavenly sword
yeah heavenly sword who got the arrow in
oh that was the worst gold to the bushes
why that was that that was ninja theory
and i you know i know
they had to utilize the new tech but it
does that slowed that game down so much
for me the combat was great but that
yeah but that broad this is what sony
does in
every generation they give you this high
tech they like you they give you a way
that you
i can see the world happening with this
i mean
at the end of the day we can't we can
make fun of certain scenarios but like
at the end does it matter like when that
god of war ii draws
oh yeah yeah people go yes it's not
gonna matter when when
or horizon zero dawn too that the day
and age of that is over at it
no it's not just oh dropping hits it
doesn't matter if you know what i say
because playstation's not dropping hits
right now is it over it doesn't mean
that so
i'm gonna tell you this this is why it's
over one in nine days is done son
like one day you can keep saying yo when
they drop this son
when my cousin come through
the impact when the cousin
you'll be like if the comes comes
through it all right once it's the
cousin come to bail you out of jail you
don't come
dude you ain't getting him how many
times he gonna bail me out though
like how many times do i gotta get in
trouble
we'll bail out and that will relieve but
that's every two to three i can't be
waiting two to three years to get bail
out of jail
they have a cadence of 24 months banger
24 months
like just because i will agree with you
it's been a while since we had like a a
huge huge banker you know what i'm
saying but
because last of us was last year
like besides that your day's gone came
out they've always had a banker every
year
yeah or what about that abe's though
yeah
and the thing about it is that this is
the first time
that you really see where you know where
where the the dude basically is in third
place
has changed the narrative around all of
gaming
right in a way that now they can't
ignore right when gamepad first came out
we wondered if sony could just get by
on being sony right and not worry about
what game pass is doing in the beginning
sure right now yeah the battlefield
yeah you know the moment it changed when
outriders came out on day one you know
another moment of change
i had to drop enough bomb last night for
that mlb the show like yeah
that game looks so good
bro
on a ps5 it looks so good and that was
like all i could say while i was
watching it though that looks so good
it's gonna look so much better xbox
series
i'm gonna tell you when it comes to like
the animations if you know
listen you know sometimes when you when
when you swing and you make contact with
the baseball
you would see like an extra animation
because it wasn't smooth the contact
wasn't smooth
now the contact is smooth and when you
look at the replay
right you see the batter's eye looking
exactly to where the contact is made
like king you don't understand how the
nuances are
right now after we finish it takes two
let's do
one game of m-o-b
it comes out tuesday tuesday for us
yeah yeah i'm gonna start streaming that
oh god
so you mean you mean it's out now for
the trials like solve comes out tuesday
listen not
the fans don't buy their games
are you implied without real gamers
all of you frauds including uh
concluding listen
you know what it is phil domination
spencer did this for me he did that for
me too you know he did that for me he
told me
king he said he got experience
he said we good so i said you know what
i mean
i was gonna wait till tuesday but the
thing is that i won't be able to play
the saturday so i'm like oh
yeah you did i can't i can't rely on
solve though like if they started doing
of all their first party stuff or you
get
access to it like four or five days
earlier and then and that hey
you think i'm waiting for it i'm
pocketing i'm pocket watching
no i'm i'm with attic i'm probably not
waiting for hey like
oh wait all right i
what you doing no i'm waiting man that's
what i'm talking
let me hit cog with this that destiny
three comes out and it's on game pass
day one you wait
myself
no you know what it is if they brought
out a new event to holyfield boxing yeah
yeah you never know everybody has they
all got that fraud alert
on us because it's a game that we will
break street dates
crazy i don't care what nobody say if
they told me
vanda holyfield right now got the new
evandal
it
they bring it back oh
when it comes to destiny if a vow was
like yo you can get it four days early
if you buy the ultimate edition
i'm reaching into my rocket you have no
idea
the smile on my face when i threw that
on and it said
it said playstation studio
yo i still couldn't believe it i was
like oh my god let's get back focused
get back
dude
hold on a second what's funny in the
transfer they did
i had to put go back home give me a
second keep talking keep it all right we
got a lot of
stuff no this is absolutely hilarious we
got those yeah we all got those
but this this mlb though yeah
it's a little it hit different when
those dudes don't have the free solution
mm-hmm yeah it does abso that's that and
that's just it
they don't have that and they you know
the refusal to do that
uh we still don't know if they knew
absolutely
they did that with that destruction
derby all-star crap that they put out
there they threw it on they joined
and they did the abe odyssey on the
playstation now
so at no point in time do you can't tell
me that you can't put your joint down
i just think to save face you needed to
do it
to say but you guys walk away from a bag
but that doesn't stop you from buying
though but they realize that they fan
base don't buy
it because it's such a it's such a it
just pushes you to xbox
yeah well if you didn't got it you get
it
all right we're good we got flame two
dollars super chat you can replace it
but it's hidden under 300 parts of the
playstation 5.
that's right there we have max the lazy
otaku
five dollars jim ryan don't touch it
don't look at it
don't think about it sony user number
four
five three four seven four what if i
adjust the playstation 5
[Laughter]
don't touch that sticker don't touch
that sticker because you know it's
coming yeah boy
don't do it then we got jd gamer five
dollars super chat i want a proper panty
dragon soccer saga remake
who's with me i'm right there with you
sir i'm with you sir
this game has been lost to history and i
want a fantasy star rpg remake oh
yeah yeah i mean fantasy star online rpg
yeah but an rpg yeah that's what i want
yeah not that's the stuff they're doing
now we can start there
no doubt shout out to the shop podcast
fuzzy belvedere in the building
5 super chat i'll purchase more games on
playstation 5 when they open up the ssd
slot i
need space time to bury this thing
put it in the dirt in the dirt there we
go
max once again the lazy otaku five
dollars if we chat the pc
xbox players looking at sony like i
thought this was the best place to play
why i got so many issues then we got
stitch with the five dollar super chat
as much uh as i bash on the switch at
least it has expandable storage and the
playstation 5 can even use a single usb
drive
salute for stitches
what's funny is that the transfer speed
between the internal and external
on the x and the s is twice faster than
ps5
i don't know that that's
10 super chat salute lords awesome show
today again thank you the lord natai
and lady megan keep up the amazing work
lords much success
wait thank you yeah they were fantastic
amazing
then we got warlord 10 super chat great
conversation obsidian's future is bright
wish we got a new vegas 2 uh question
joke
question joke yeah we didn't go to new
vegas too but you know
yeah lots of other products are going to
be talking about this in this interview
got get the likes up no doubt yeah
man they really are kind of like to go
i really like the fact that they just
had to make it clear that
there's no evil oversight bothering you
mm-hmm
yeah i love them they're doing what they
want to do facts
fuzzy onesies i like the comments
they're like like you know megan was
like look you know
i'm sure everyone does things
differently she's like but i've been
to a lot of different developers and i
just personally feel like the way they
do narrative is better than most
people yeah yeah they did it like they
were humbly
flexible like some of the teams come to
us
but i'm not gonna lie to their dialogue
trees
is the best it's like you don't get like
two two lines of dialogue
and the way it's really get out that's
the thing when cog mentioned mass effect
mass effect is the closest proximity to
that if you go back to mass effect
it feels very stiff and still very
simple compared to that yeah
very simple but yo i can't wait to see
what a vowel looks like in terms of oh
they got another plc
for um did you guys see that no we've
been
that's a private division deal now
everything now is
excellent because i didn't want i didn't
want to i'm sure they're all working on
it i didn't want to
touch on the fact that it didn't have
any series x or series s
uh yeah enhancement remember that was in
the private division they gave me
60 frames in the auto hdr but that was
about it with that did you guys notice
that they were referring to a game that
felt like it was unannounced
yes like yes this
fuzzy once again five dollar super chat
the solution is to put the playstation 5
in the series x mini fridge
[Music]
357 gigabytes is definitely not enough
space on the series s but at least xbox
has the storage expansion ready day one
yeah yeah see the thing is with that
where if you get the storage expansion
for the s again people get the s for
different reasons but at that point
you probably get the x right if you can
get your hands on it yeah but if you
have that
external hooked up from day one you were
gucci
i'm gonna tell you right now the moment
they have some sort of
attachable screen for that s
you already know their dudes already
made that mm-hmm yeah they have they i
was looking up the dudes that made the
ones for the xbox one
and the x it doesn't quite fit so
they're working on that
oh okay no doubt then we have dan
lazzaro five dollar super chat
uh i find out i find iop and try to
watch other gaming pods and i can't
you guys got the right energy all these
other pods make me
best xbox pod on youtube we're not an
xbox
xbox podcast um my just because i have
uh a large person at this point there's
nothing
yeah yeah listen yeah they don't believe
us
sovereign is playstation even though
he's playing mob on the xbox
um
[Laughter]
you want to get sage oh out of jail
jail stage five dollars super chat gonna
be honest playstation five feels a
little like a scheme from a shady feud
i feel like i can't trust it like i
can't risk my investment with them
yeah it's true now we gotta put the
crest in the chat but dan lazaro the
newest member
of the round thank you brother oh
actually i completely forgot who was the
individual that joined the room at the
start of the podcast that we didn't read
them off
i don't know i forgot that a long time i
remember the moment he said the name i
already talked about
all right lord hollow welcome to the
realm thank you we apologize
that we we lost to be fair it didn't
show up in our chat for some reason
yeah i i luckily i had seen it and i was
just like i kept it it was still on my
screen
put the crush in the yeah yes then we
got
sage once again five dollars we chat i'm
waiting to play the show on game pass
just out of petty spike
that's right i want them to know i
didn't spend anything for it and i'll
play on android
videos inbound oh christopher heart
super chat you have to read that key
that's christmas my heart yeah yeah i
don't think he's funny
he's not next though he's next yeah he's
not next so get ready because you got to
read it
okay let me let me find it
okay i got it i i'll i got you um
sage five dollars super chat 93 gigabyte
gears 5
transfer from series x internal the
seagate expansion card is
under two minutes yes test it yourself
yeah it's christopher
yeah yeah it's best to download and then
transfer between
yeah i agree sage all right respect to
the iron lords
go watch the show the godfather of
harlem on the 25th
next sunday my nephew joshua has
a recurring
that's what's up though i was watching a
little bit of that yesterday that's uh
yeah
i got you johnson's story yeah yeah
yeah my great great grandfather yeah
okay i'm on that christopher yeah
don't know what else we got then we got
gamers play hold up i got jumped
damn hold on zero i got it follow super
chat hope to collab with the lords in
the news near future
gamers play will return hashtag
[Laughter]
he's not going nowhere he's doing a
wonderful job
i i actually i think he was the best man
for the job
thank you so much for hiring sony
here in the front of that with his arm
up
i think it's a code giveaway time
bernard miller as well put the question
in the chat thank you for the two newest
members of the round
thank you so we got something we got
some stuff that's getting ready to
happen
um we're about to do some giveaways and
some stuff like that
you know we're talking in the background
also i got to get ready to put up a new
video because i'm going to start asking
for
animators yes um artists
uh we're getting ready to take this
thing to the next level we're going to
bust the roof off this joint
um so um i'm getting ready to hit you
guys up and
remember the last time i told you guys
to get at us because i needed a rap
artist and nobody looked at me shout out
to dallas for checking it out the park
for giving us one of the hottest intros
that we've had
and i told you guys this time don't sit
on your hands i don't want nobody scared
hit me up we're gonna when the video
goes out then you'll get at me well
let's go
yeah yeah no doubt because it's gonna be
a different vibe oh my god
hey ready guys i got something to give
away
yeah i'm gonna i put a code in there but
this next one's going just to the the
members so give me
i'm gonna have to come up with a
question because people will be
snatching that room
people be
then we got oh michael aka best size
finest 10 super chat well i'm not
surprised that playstation 5 is failing
good for them oh my god rip the ps5
is done uh van moose gotta go
xbox is live and yes lords god bless
celeste
oh hell i feel spencer i'm done
he called them field spencer
wow that was a whole lot of work i got
one
i'm definitely going to butcher his name
what was his name i don't want to
butcher
the the writer that we just had on the
thai the top
okay he said he wrote a specific
character a companion what was that
companion good question oh
good question you messed up
were you guys listening
what were you doing listen did you just
show up
for the people who actually was learning
i don't see no names
sorry guys flame flame got it playing
god wow okay flame was on
the flame is on it you know i know
flames are flame was on it shout out to
flynn because he was on it since i
hit me up on twitter it was going to be
on a day ago so flame been oh he's like
oh
i'm sitting here so he did his best he
deserved that he deserves it
fantastic oh then we got max delazio
taco five dollars super chat
finding out finding any out wings
what somebody said what don't say little
man
finding any outweighing reasons to have
a ps5 is like solving a danganronpa
murder case
what happened and how do we attempt to
solve it
then we got bernard miller five dollars
we chat found your podcast about six
months ago
you guys have the best not an xbox
podcast podcast around
that was good i had to join the room
that was good
then we have tony brian five dollars to
the chat love iop
day five of my one man campaign it's
gonna happen watching your guys growth
is amazing
yo shout out to tony i think i know what
you talking about you don't want to be
putting up on twitter you want the home
eater the wrestling dude
i know what you talk about yeah i know
salute salute
i know that we're caught up man i
haven't had it i haven't had a chance to
say my favorite names today where are
you guys
we got this last topic
so addict what's going on man square
enix what's going on
so there's uh you know obviously there's
a lot of rumors always going around
microsoft's buying this
microsoft's buying that now it looks
like oh
okay first off square enix has come out
and they have they've debunked this but
in our experience that doesn't mean
anything
uh and you can even go look up uh lord
hogue he has a good video out on there
uh all that is is pr speak we agreeing
to anything we ain't denying anything
uh so you know what i want to bring to
the room what i want to talk about
is score annex is up for sale possibly
and i want to get who you think should
own them
and why you think should own them and
pretty much king why should square on
why shouldn't xbox own square
okay so right now they're the the king
and the western rpgs
at this moment you know um when the rpgs
start rolling in we expect
you know these rpgs to hit and resonate
with the western market
um i think square when they acquired
enix
they were trying to uh get into the
western market
get into the european market and i don't
think it hit the way they wanted to
like with tomb raider and stuff like
that i think with
um outriders they finally
uh got a foothold into
uh western gaming in a sense that they
this is finally they really have an
identity you don't look at it as a
square enix game to be honest with you
and then i think that was all
due to launching day and date inside
game pass
so we see where certain games can falter
and where certain games can grow with
the uh
the arm of game pass and also being that
we just had obsidian
saying that microsoft doesn't uh become
the board doesn't want you to assimilate
to their
their way of thinking wants the
developer to grow
in his own space and allows them the
freedom but just giving them financial
stability
i think that allows square enix to grow
in spaces and take chances that we
haven't
um seen them take that just just to
nurture real quick uh
in their type of space when it comes to
the jrpgs like
doing risk with those type of games
is so risky but it could pay off so much
and they're not able to do it as much
because they're constantly you know we
got it
financially they would be under
constrained so i want them to have that
financial freedom that microsoft will
give them
i don't feel that sony would be able to
afford that same luxury
because financially they're cash
strapped so i think
that will be going from the same level
and not elevating your status it's like
going from one dude that's on welfare
your welfare they own welfare young
welfare together
instead of going to a dude that actually
is affluent and has
uh you know wealth and can do something
for you so
yeah i would like them to pick the guy
that can actually enhance their life
more of the same no doubt no doubt lord
son of man what do you think about the
rumors all this stuff going on
or is it conjecture like where you at
with this whole thing was square
you muted sorry sorry sorry
um if the conversations are actually
happening
they're not going to talk about it
because they're a publicly traded
company
they cannot if they go out there and
their stock prices go
up or down based on what's what's
speculated and talked about it
it makes them exactly it's like you
can't do that you just can't do that so
they got to be quiet no matter what
happens um
if it is happening i'm gonna be honest i
like them by themselves
i think i think they're eating right now
we talked about this before how
they they have games that fit on the
sony side
they have games that fit on the xbox
side they can eat from both
sides and and if you even look at
octopath traveler which first came out
on the switch they have something for
the switch too
so it's like and you have a triangle
like a triangle strategy
so for me they're eating on all ends
they don't need to worry about being
purchased
um i think they're good if it does
happen obviously that relationship they
already have with playstation for their
biggest titles
that makes sense but you know money
talks
money does talk and xbox i can't look
i cannot say that this is not a good fit
because if they
once again if they keep trying to get
into that japanese market
right in a real way and they just can't
do it
microsoft has shown that they're willing
just to buy their way in
i mean look we know that i'll jump in we
know the bag this is
definitely the wrong possibility we're
not just because of the bag like we
never
never say never i'm never gonna say
never i'm never gonna disrespect
you know what i'm saying we know where
the millions is that right but at the
end of the day
it's like you know it i had this
conversation with addict
and we were just like at some point it's
like microsoft could buy everybody so
there has to be a limit
at what they're going right you know so
so my thing it's more
more so i think i shout to colin because
colin said this before when he was with
us like
there comes a point where when you do
all these buying
you know the special part about bethesda
is they were always their self
center max excuse me they were that
self-contained publishing entity that
could manage themselves
microsoft doesn't have to be as much
hands-on with them the thing is we got
to look at
what's on matt booty's plate right
because it's matt right
he's got to go to all the different
studios and say okay what's going on
whatever
at a certain number it has to be a
number where it's like okay this is
getting unmanageable we're going to have
to hire more or
not yeah get at it i think that's why
they're aiming for these big companies
i have to pay a lot more money right but
they have a self-sustainable industry
they don't have to really do it so look
you know if microsoft jumped in yeah
this would be crazy this would be
a major blow you know because we know
that they are synonymous
with sony me personally i would solve
i think somebody shot because the report
wasn't even bloomberg the report
was the cte whatever and they're like
investment bankers
like to me this is someone trying to
gauge where the price at
you know what i'm saying so we know they
more than bethesda so let's
jump it up and then to to someone's
point like what hulk saying
square did not say anything addict's
right square did i say anything in that
statement that denied anything
they're just like yo um nobody made an
offer that does not mean no one ain't
talk to you fam
like you don't say like so so we got all
they pretty much says we ain't
comfortable we didn't get it official
hasn't been delivered it's on its way
but it's not here shout out to the lord
of
hogue always breaks this stuff down and
he lit that that
lit that statement that everybody's
running with it they denied
that means nothing that is legal speak
they can still be flirting with whoever
they want to flirt with
that's right until it offers all the
somebody in them dm
you know you don't feel the king of the
slide in yeah the way he the way he
wrote whatever
[Music]
happens i you know i'll be shocked you
know but i would solve
i think square's in this unique position
they've got all these ips these juicy
ips that everybody
want yeah and they could sit here and be
like well
you know sony you know microsoft over
here they they say we get this bag for
we put it in gamepad what what you
giving
what you what's nothing absolutely
[Music]
i do have a couple thoughts on this i
don't think that's gonna be like forever
i think sony's going to start paying
extra money to lock stuff out of
gameplay so it would be smart
because i do think we're going a
direction where they can no longer play
both sides now they could play both
sides with certain games
right but sony going to make sure if we
helping you
you ain't helping that right yeah it
feels like they did that already because
look there's been
you know the two years the one year
exclusivity on final fantasy came and
went
no comments on anything right so we
don't know how much sony paid to keep it
all keep it
as long as possible they could have
extended it right those are the deals
behind the thing
but i mean that would have to be talked
about though like that this i heard that
already
i heard that i heard i heard it twice
and
um that would have to be like the re-up
will have to be like you know they re-up
the the the
extension of it honestly i think the
game is coming
i just think they're just waiting like i
said this on boom on friday
mm-hmm because boom thought it was
dangerous
the day is out the day it's coming
i'm like no that's not how i work like
that
and i i didn't want to you know just let
them know that but it's just
mob the show this is this is huge let's
just
let's not just get past two oh no
tuesday is
this is a wreck they pop in bottles bro
like bottles
if you don't think bottles was popped or
being popped on tuesday
bottles will be popped and they will
gauge this whole week
let this soak in let all that get into
your pause
let you let you feel this pause again
[Laughter]
and then the following week you will
have more news but this is a big
good gaming news yeah so i don't think
that final fantasy there's no need for
you to steal your own thunder that's
what i'm saying you know right now you
you steal your own thunder when it died
down for the week and then following
where you blake
and final fantasy is coming because we
didn't get what's coming out for game
pass for
the other half of this month something
as serious as final fantasy that's not
just throwing it on twitter
they're going to want to save that for
an event or something like that yeah
what
comes to square enix i don't think
they're buying them but i do think
they've tried to
or at least i don't think they tried yet
on a conversation
uh but i do think that you know
if there was a company to [ __ ] sony
it would be square units
and i think getting square enix
is definitely one of those scenarios
where regardless what anyone thinks
that that is that is really hurting sony
because one of
that sony is doing the combat game pass
in the combat
all these studios that are like we're
just going to double down on
timed exclusives we're going to try to
buy as many second third-party uh
deals that we possibly can and the
biggest person they're doing that with
this who
score enos you know if they took that if
they took
that piece off the board i i honestly
don't feel like sony could recover from
that very let me ask you this
my thing is though why do you have to
necessarily take it off the ball when
you could just
keep their ips a game pass and just
kind of fight that way you know what i'm
saying like one of the things you don't
necessarily got to buy the whole
building in this case yeah i didn't
necessarily have the bottle of bethesda
but they wanted all that stuff no no
for sure official but it goes back to
what cox said about what colin said
colin said specifically he's like yo
the reason i think they should sell all
those xbox ip
on playstation now it's because you make
the argument
look yeah it's on playstation but it's
gonna cost you seventy minutes
right exactly just just that's winning
that like can you say that
he's dropping the bombshell they want
they they want
them in their ecosystem they want them
paying the fifteen dollars
it's like we said multiple times with
the bethesda things getting them over
there
paying that 170 dollars let's be real
here it's not like you know besides the
fall ads but there's the games we're
selling millions upon millions upon
millions of stuff
so it's better to have them for like
kind of directing them towards pc and
towards
xbox that's like look like we don't want
just the one sound let's be real here a
lot of people probably only bought one
but that's the game
money i get that i get that i guess well
i i say this for
the the uh for the um squaring next
thing
all right first of all they're publisher
all right so we established that they're
no longer like
looking for little indies because like
you said my booty has a ton on his plate
right now
would run in these studios so now when
you're buying a
a publisher that can actually run this
show run their self
and then with littleton uh uh not so
much oversight you go over there check
this stuff out you know reports and
stuff coming back
this is it won't hurt sony in the short
run all right because they do have games
coming from square enix that is going to
be
launching soon and in the next two years
yeah
right so at no point in time would it
hurt them
and microsoft would not void or cancel
of course
and you know would be crazy king i know
this is completely out of the realm
if they have it came up with a deal for
the remake too because it's not been
formally announced
and microsoft buys that and they lock
that off the place
i don't think that that would happen i
think i think there's a deal in place
but i i do say this right when it when
it comes to square enix
and i do believe because it's publicly
traded
right yes that's what it is okay this is
this is about to say
this is the hugest problem with a
publicly traded company
microsoft can go in and host a takeover
by purchasing the majority of shares
they don't really have to sit there and
talk to square about
anything they can go to shareholders
purchase their
shares have a majority in the company
i came to your dms
when you do stuff like that you want
them to work for you so you hostile
takeover
first of all you got them like the odd
world inhabitants
of servitude you won't
[Laughter]
i don't know personal
thoughts is i don't want them to buy
square because i know that's going to be
a very
expensive purchase
and me i don't want them putting uh you
know i would rather them invest in the
smaller stuff so there's more room to
build
right because i feel like if they buy
something like sega which i feel like
more in the realm of reality than
something
square enix you know there's more money
to play around with going on forward
all right they just they're buying
that's gonna be 10 billion plus
they just spend 20 billion buying a
a voice uh oh yeah yeah yeah uh
okay 20 billion microsoft just you spend
20 billion i get it i get it they they
put out
20 billion
i send you flowers i tried to be nice
now i gotta buy the company that you
work for
i gotta buy the building that you live
in you gonna see me
die can i struggle
microsoft has worked so hard to to get
their public relations
up that they are not that would destroy
the japanese that would destroy that
would destroy there would be
you don't want people working under
those type of conditions
and then ultimately the thing that no
one else is talking about is that
squid they're not like sega all the way
in a sense but they like do
manga and figures and toys
that's not that part of their business
is not interested mark myself not
interested that's why the sega thing
makes sense because
sega's getting rid of all that extra
stuff yeah right so so when you got a
an entity that has all these different
components
square's just more than just games for
them yeah it's a whole bunch of things
right so if microsoft does the hostile
drake then it comes
all right you're going to start laying
people off because you know you don't
need your manga division we don't need
your whatever division
relationship
like at the end of the day phil spencer
has fought
so hard to gain um a little bit of
respect over there yeah
and if you go over them like squares
ours
one of the great things that they're
doing is letting us
beat us there's no board here comes king
with the
hostiles
though like if they did something like
that you would have all the
like from software company they've been
working with like yo that's some dirty
stuff we're never working with you again
right we don't know that
you don't know
at the end of the
like that japanese culture it's it's
really different
if they see something like that like
that's why the japanese
uh government always be buying stock in
their companies to make sure stuff stays
within
yeah it it's just like if you go that
far
like you might as well kiss all
relations with japan go that's not gonna
happen and they really like us
and they're talking to us and we are
about to get married because we ain't
buying up on stock
takeover it's like we just want a acg
podcast
it's like like we just stay friends with
benefits baby like why we gotta
no no no
this is what microsoft have to do he
gonna do just like this hey boo boo
and you're gonna slide that ring on yeah
and all those games see
this is the fear now listen you know
what let's get to the fair points
because i'm sick this is this is why
this is a conversation
this is the reason why it's a
conversation the playstation dudes know
they only have a couple of bullets in a
chamber
right you know that you got your own
joints right yeah
but then your own joints ain't secure
because tools they showed you
anything can happen anything is possible
all right so
there you go so you now you're shaking
your gun is shaking you
got a couple of bullets left you that
dude waving
we actually take a square enix bullet
out of your gun you only got like two
bullets left now you playing rush
that's what i did say i agree i if they
did somehow get square enix
it would be like a cut the juggler if
sony like yeah because it would be
so hard for them to re recommend those
are the only games you're looking
forward to on there
and the thing the fact the relationship
if it was to happen which i still don't
think that but
if it was to happen yeah it's a bad look
because
remember like square squared in there
for sony
when sony was down with the whole
nintendo thing you know what i'm saying
and they created they helped you know
with the system and and and
final fantasy you know what i'm saying
bringing that over there and then even
at one point
sony had the ten percent when the square
was going through it right they had the
ten percent um
interest in them so it again and again
the relationship you know saying
you know with a japanese company like
addict was saying like it would be
shocking to me if that happened and i
agree if it did happen
it that would be a huge if scott would
you know that would be crazy
it wouldn't even be scar enough like if
scoring is willingly sold
to an american company like that
that old people would side-eye them yeah
exactly
shout out to slo saying what i'm saying
too he said if forcing your way to
ownership really work with japanese
developers and publishers then it
wouldn't work when mark
when microsoft tried to blind nintendo
and square back into that
remember when nintendo laughed them up
the laugh come out the room because
nintendo wasn't publicly traded they
i see see people come i mean you're not
wrong and they can be like yo
yeah nintendo laughed them out that's
right i'm not in the streets
get out of my house but if you about
these streets
you could be purchased by whoever i
could just look i could just see phil
spencer coming in i want to speak to
your boss he's busy today
well i'm his boss now so you better
i think ted said what they did that's
all i got but yeah i don't think i don't
think
this is a real fun one it's a phone call
i do
think microsoft's buying something but
it ain't square if it buy them
if
i would have to join king with his
foolishness like
i honestly feel like like much more do
they gotta do
man they don't to me they out here
moving and shaking already
if they buy square i'm willing to come
out openly say
sony in trouble trouble in trouble
it's over the fighters
chat if microsoft bought square enix do
you think sony would be in trouble
put uh put a put a one for yes put a two
for no yeah
and put a three for king is right
they've done already
they're going three with king though
because they say i think they say it is
over there okay so
one two and three a lot of ones with a
three and a fuzzy snuck at three in
all right threes are hitting up yeah
there's a lot of them big big clams
oh so that's double this awful that's
that's what that means okay
y'all savage anyway let's get these
super chats and get them out of here
y'all
uh we got flame with the two dollar
super chat all right so
mass er wreck and lord roughness
thank you i appreciate it
there we go brett bring him five dollars
you know what i'm not buying wb games
not selling no longer for sale doesn't
mean they aren't selling
regular put bad zeros and then vr over
all right hold on a second then we got
jimbo jangles
the 10 super sony looking like papa doc
at the end of eight miles speechless
crowd turned he's scared he's shook
there's no such thing as a halfway crook
bars
that ball deep that shook one let's go
i can't read stuff like that i'm too
white
you can't you can't read it with the
right cadence you know you gotta i'm
gonna read that just like i'd read
everything else
then we got dan the man cunningham five
dollar super chat greetings lawrence i
hope microsoft by square
then they wouldn't treat us like third
class gamers like they do
and it's just getting better let's get
back when we got saved
games and game pass right now shout out
we got sage five dollars if we chat
remember what i said about square
cog and how unthinkable that seemed xbox
japan dot dot dot square song
yeah i don't know man i'm still waiting
don't say it bro yeah
get them bang them five dollars they
just get them to buy them all oh well
bingo five dollars super chat is going
to be massive for xbox microsoft isn't
just coming for sony's lunch money and
they're also coming for their yu-gi-oh
card
damn cards not my pokemon they do
technically they do technically on the
rights to whatever
you do but but but no that's konami
like the konami's like destroyed that
game so i wouldn't even care we want we
want kunami too
final fantasy tactics remake if they at
fun speculation
if they ever had a tactics remake you
would officially hear me be a
a complete fanboy which today i gotta
post that uh the next
final fantasy showdown yeah you gotta do
i like those little polls you're doing
mm-hmm i don't even know who won the
last one
now we got black ronin five dollars over
chat great interview great show
made my slow sunday a great day thank
you brother love thank y'all for pulling
up
too yeah for sure uh max the lazy otaku
two
super chat game pass meme coming soon
get twitter ready later
then we got clutch man five dollar super
chat great obsidian interview and shout
out to the living split screen podcast
uh my favorite show alongside iop yeah
big shout out to pong soul and steel
over there
yeah yeah those guys do great work
then we got lord of roughness five pound
super chat
the slander the x got for the ui and
controller looking the same
now it looks like the whole if it's not
broke approach wins
the book of acts i gotta hit him with
the book yes that's
exactly what delivery and all that was
in the game
then we got michael aka best size fine
it's five dollars super chat
uh lord just own it this is more xbox
than sony y'all got a better chance of
having phil spencer than jim ryan any
day serious and yes
r.i.p playstation possibly we're still
going to get the sony dabs on man
yeah man whenever they show we got them
believe tyler five dollars if we take he
makes it seem like they're afraid of us
they they they might be scared of the
king they might be scared again
you just seen how to call them they're
the preferred choice of the tcl owner
and we got malik tyler five dollars if
you have phil spencer we can do this the
easy way
the hard way you're gonna be mine
i know what y'all referencing y'all bad
i know what y'all referencing
stop it
there we got aaron with the five dollars
jack king did it i'm dead now
so the raven flow is next the raven flow
two dollar super chat
a purchase of square would force japan
to buy xbox
or japan the whole country
so i do i do want to put some in the
chat real quick i need some i need some
opinions
yes all my final fantasy heads in that
chat put four titles you think i should
put in this next uh
showdown four final fantasy titles put
them all together
no doubt you got uh all those awesome
chats
super chat i i like raven flows thinking
that's the last word in the building so
we all caught up soon yes sir
out of here man we going with prop today
i like this yeah
i need this i got to get to my um um my
outriders no doubt
how nice of you my inventory glitch
new iop fold log that poll up should be
up now
with all the latest rumors regarding
video game company acquisitions
which pairing do you think makes the
most sense
choices are a sony and square enix
b microsoft and sega c
microsoft for nintendo or d i don't care
10 cents still out here scared everybody
in these gaming streets
that is the choices please rock the vote
it's up on lawrence.net yo please go to
the lawsuit game down there you'll hit
those votes man
it really helps us yeah
we've got a lot of stuff happening with
lots of game in the net so please
hit the website let me let me plug a
little bit hit the website
launchinggaming.net
go to the poll it's up now get your vote
let your voice be where my
put that in the chat put it in the chat
so then go straight to it yeah yeah
yeah well how about the co-host help me
i don't i don't have access to it
i don't i don't have about someone help
me well i'm talking
about that but um
people keep asking me king when we're
going to do our next uh it takes too
long oh you guys
you know listen a lot of things happen
we're not static individuals that don't
have
hustle you know we we actually have we
actually have jobs and lives and stuff
like that so whenever we can uh what
time would you be available tomorrow
um tomorrow is monday
i don't think i have anything to do
tomorrow but um
i gotta i got a couple of things to do
so um
just hit me up after that we'll figure
it out you know day before the type of
stuff is kind of weird but i'm super
chat
about it yeah we got sage to five
dollars if we chat
remember half baked microsoft this nasty
nate to the teacher give me your fruit
cup
you're out of control then we got malik
tyler five dollars which happens
spencer square enix kunami soccer
what's your price yeah i'm not feeling
that kunami thing you gotta
pronounce that correctly
absolutely there we go with the five
dollars super chat
those pens are waiting with the grape
jelly and the grease i like you and i
want you to
like it y'all better stop i know what
doing i know what you're doing i'm gonna
stop it's the lord's day
y'all out here fornicating out here stop
it
anyway that's what i got please rock the
vote it's up there thank you oh wow they
still
see yes i find it psyphonics with the
10-pound super chat wanted to know
square would make xbox much stronger in
europe
slash uk as well as asia squares
merchandise and anime and manga would be
a boon as they have always
outsourced this aspect in the past yeah
what's going on you can follow me on
twitter at lordaddicts
twitter twitter thank you i like that
you can find me on youtube the gaming
addict
um keep in mind i will be streaming uh
demon souls tomorrow at 1pm
if king is available in the afternoon i
guess i'll double stream tomorrow and
stream that with him too and i'm
probably gonna have an addict uh
world tuesday going up so we get a new
addict
keep keep checking on the on the twitter
you know uh
i still put my twitter in there so so
they know uh to get all that information
thank you hustle we appreciate you
brother addicts world it's fire love the
streams like what you got going on love
the engagement
on social media what you're doing with
the final fantasy stuff is very cool
thank you sir you have been killing it
on fire
even though you didn't put the lord's
gaming in the chat but i still love
everything else you do
anyway lord solve making his annual
podcast guesting appearance that's it
he's done for the year
i'm not i'm actually not done that's
what i'm talking about the people once
solved especially
after the colin episode i got so much
positive feedback from you
people loved what you had they said it
was the heart and soul of it you killed
it
where can you find people find you what
you got going on sir uh you know you can
find me on
twitter lordstop iop bx shopping and psn
xbox live i'll be playing
mob the show on my xbox
i'll be doing that um and next friday
i'm not going to say where i'm going to
be next friday evening
oh you guys could could figure it out uh
because it hasn't been announced yet so
but i will be on a podcast next friday
evening you realize that you realize
there's like three pockets yeah exactly
[Laughter]
um no doubt and then of course i'm still
trying to figure out i got to figure out
what
uh lady saab so i can make time for it
to get on uh with gaz and asa over there
oh that's what's up we appreciate it you
gotta get that here shout out to the
sauce
shout out to asic guys gabe on daily
yeah that's a good one that's a good one
yeah yeah
and of course the legendary lord king
the prophet
making us laugh today with his
aggressive corporate tactics
what do you have going on today sir well
um right now i'm gonna get on this
outriders and grind grinding stuff out
pulse
um i might be on 2xp uh very soon
just trying to work stuff out nice
because the
times is different and i work nights so
you are not getting me
past five o'clock you know stuff like
that may have to do a special session
or early in the daytime or something
like that but you can find me on twitter
king david otw out there i'm not giving
them smoking nobody because dudes
they're tired
they've been waving the white flag but
too bad the white flag
on that you've been waving the wrong
king is like screw your surrender i
don't want your surrender
this is war corporate king bro he's
vicious suspicious
no doubt i can see out here moving and
shaking
love and then of course you don't know
what's mean lord cognito man again yo
salute
salute to see everybody pull up what we
do to develop
intros i know sometimes they don't
always do the biggest but to see
everybody pull up
and just engage and listen yeah actually
a really good uh
good call pull up today yeah yeah
you know to the realm if you enjoyed it
we really like trying to do these things
and
shout out to those four down votes shout
out to the four down votes that hate it
didn't want to learn everything
[Laughter]
they know this is exactly how they do
too
we got a ton of fun stuff playing man
stay tuned
more fun more stuff attic knows soft no
kick though
again yeah this summer's all the way to
the summer it's gonna be lit so please
stay tuned thank you for rocking out get
the super chats up i think we missed the
cup
no we just missed we just got one 108
dragons tv five dollar super chat wow
great interviews comes great
responsibility and you guys are awesome
facts yo salute away man support the uh
dragons
den podcast i believe he does that on
saturday
later peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
wow